[musique]
Marion Maréchal, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Oui. Alors donc je m'appelle Mario
Maréchal, j'ai 34 ans, je suis maman de
deux filles mariées. Je suis candidate
aux élections européennes du 9 juin
prochain. Je suis vice-présidente d'un
parti politique qui s'appelle
Reconquête. Et avant cela et bien j'ai
été député, conseil régional et puis
j'ai fondé une école de sciences
politiques qui s'appelle LIEP.
Alors pour commencer cette interview,
petite précision oratoire. Euh euh
vous n'avez pas reçu les questions, on
vous a contacté euh et en fait on est
très content de vous recevoir parce
qu'on nous a fait remarquer très
récemment qu'on avait pas assez de gens
de droite voire d'extrême droite. Donc
on est très content de discuter avec
vous. Première question.
Mais je ne suis pas d'extrême droite.
Je suis pas d'extrême droite. Euh je je
vous je vous parce que comme je sais que
j'ai le temps. Ah non oui.
Et donc qu'est-ce que vous pensez euh de
la dernière sortie de RSF et de l'Arcom
? Je suis scandalisé puisque évidemment
c'est très inquiétant pour la suite pour
une raison simple, c'est que on a donc
un conseil d'état qui revient sur une
décision de l'ARCOM pour expliquer que
doren avant non seulement ils font
comptabiliser les temps d'antennes des
partis politiques et des personnalités
politiques et j'y reviendrai parce que
moi j'en suis directement [grognement]
la la victime si je puis dire mais
au-delà de ça il faudrait donc ficher
les journalistes à partir de critères
ambigu ou douteux ou flou déterminés
quelle serait leur appartenance
politique et donc en déduire le temps
d'antenne qui leur serait octroyé et le
tout sur une chaîne privée parce que
évidemment on le voit qu'il s'agit des
amendes ou des remontrances de manière
générale c'est toujours ou Europain ou c
news qui en font principalement les
frais je m'en
ces news ils ont fait quelques sorties
de des drifts difficiles
ouais je sais pas si c'est ça le le vrai
moteur puisque là en l'occurrence je
m'en remets à ce que disait Pascal pro
il tente d'inviter souvent des gens de
gauche qui refusent de venir sur le
plateau et je vous dis je m'en étonne
pas puisque l'ancien ministre de la
culture
avait expliqué qu'elle envisageait
potentiellement de pouvoir soutenir une
décision de l'ARCOM qui supprimerait la
fréquence de ces news au prétexte que
justement cette chaîne ne respecterait
pas la liberté d'expression.
Nous, on a des difficultés à avoir des
gens de droite et d'extrême droite et et
donc merci d'être là. Donc vous avez une
personne de droite ici. Euh et mais je
m'étonne en tout cas du silence de du
ministre de la culture puisque Rachid
Adati qui est connu quand même pour être
je sais pas une forte voix euh
bizarrement on n'a rien dit et je
m'étonne aussi même du silence de la
Commission parce que vous savez que ces
dernières années la Commission
européenne a fait preuve d'une ingérence
toute particulière pour aller faire
respecter soi-disant l'état de droit au
nom de grands principes et de grandes
valeurs euh soi-disant pioché dans les
traités notamment en Hongrie, en
Pologne. On va pas refaire toute
l'histoire avec les menaces de sanction,
la rétention de de d'aides qui n'ont pas
été versées de ce fait-là. Et là, une
fois de plus, bizarrement, les grandes
valeurs de l'Union européenne ne
semblent pas suffisamment empfeint en ce
qui concerne ces news et la droite. Donc
voilà,
vous connaissez le le vieil adage de
Julian Assange.
Non, pas
la censure. Qu'est-ce que révèle la
censure ? La censure révèle la peur.
Oui.
Bon,
mais je suis d'accord mais je rebondis
sur ce que vous dites. Je pense que je
pense que demain ces news pourraient se
voir retirer sa fréquence. Je vous le
dis. Je pense que au regard de ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui politiquement dans le
pays, on a une élite, un bloc centriste,
une gauche, j'ai envie de dire, un
gauchisme culturel qui se sent menacé.
Pas gauchisme, on aime pas cette
expression.
Alors c'est diffamatoire.
C'est pas que c'est diffamatoire, c'est
que c'est
c'est méprisant. Mais vous avez raison.
Mais le gauchisme culturel pour moi,
dans mon esprit, c'est méprisant. ne
supporte pas les gens qui disent les
droits tard ou les gauchistes. Il faut
que les gens se respectent pour
commencer à se comprendre.
D'accord. Alors dans ce cas-là, je ne
suis pas d'extrême droite parce que ça
aussi c'est même pire que méprisant.
C'est diffamatoire et en plus c'est faux
et c'est et c'est et on se positionne
sur le plan moral parce qu'aujourd'hui
en fait c'est un étendard pour
disqualifier moralement l'autre. Voilà.
Donc la gauche culturelle, alors si vous
préférez, terme plus neutre et donc
comme ils se sentent menacés dans leur
position, dans leur poste, dans leur
mandat, et bien je pense qu'ils vont
faire feu de tout bois. Donc je n'exclus
pas que cette hypothèse un jour arrive
sur la table.
Bon parenthèse fermée, on va peut-être
la réouvrir un peu plus tard. Je n'ai
que 1h45 avec vous. On va essayer de
gratter un petit peu avec votre
autorisation. Je sais que vous êtes
attendu après derrière.
On va parler géopolitique, on va parler
finances, on va parler immigration, on
va parler flux migratoire, on va parler
réchauffement climatique, tout un tas de
choses. Vous voulez choisir quoi en
premier ?
Alors moi je vous pose une autre
question avant que vous choisissiez.
C'est vous le patron hein.
Profitez-en
si ma femme vous entendait.
Ah oui, c'est pas vous le patron [rires]
dans la cuisine, c'est moi le patron.
[grognement] Et donc
vous vous présentez aux élections
européennes, quelles sont votre vos
forces et vos faiblesses ? [soupir]
Ah oui, en fait c'est pas c'est pas
c'est de la psychanalyse là
euh
politique. Alors on va se positionner
sur le plan politique.
On a envie de comprendre ce qu'il y a
dans votre tête. Mais mais mes forces,
disons qu'aujourd'hui c'est quand même
une relative expérience, même si elle
est toujours à consolider puisque comme
je disais, moi j'ai été j'ai été député,
j'ai été présidente d'un groupe
d'opposition au conseil régional en
provinçal Côte d'Azur.
J'ai passé 5 ans à fonder une école et
être directrice générale du d'une école
supérieure. Je suis revenu en en
politique dans un contexte ça fait en
faisant plein d'erreurs. On pourra en
reparler si vous voulez, mais euh j'ai
appris de ces erreurs en un temps en un
temps euh rapide. En tout cas, j'essaie
tous les jours de d'en tirer profit et
donc c'est c'est ma force, je dirais.
Euh et puis les faiblesses, c'est que
aujourd'hui je suis mais je trouve que
c'est des faiblesses enthousiasmantes en
ce sens que je suis aujourd'hui tête de
liste d'un jeune parti qui est encore
peu connu des Français, dont la marque
est pas forcément identifiée et donc je
suis challenger dans cette élection. Euh
donc euh tout est à faire et tout est à
construire.
Quelles sont les menaces que vous euh
vous identifiez pour les 5 à 10 ans à
venir ? Les menaces géopolitiques,
économiques et tout ce qui va
Alors, je vais pas vous surprendre. Le
le premier la première menace qui est le
moteur de mon combat, c'est la menace,
je dirais civilisationnelle au sens
large, c'est-à-dire la menace sur la
continuité historique de notre pays et
sur bah la perpétuation de son être, de
son identité, de sa culture, de son mode
de vie à travers bah deux choses. D'une
part, l'immigration, la perte de
contrôle sur l'immigration, qu'elle soit
d'ailleurs légale ou illégale, je pense
qu'on en reviendra. Et puis bah tous les
corolaires hein qui vont avec cette
perte de contrôle, c'est-à-dire d'une
part euh bah une explosion de
l'insécurité, euh une une islamisation
du pays avec tout ce que ça représente
de conflit civilisationnel sur le sol
français et puis et puis euh des
difficultés économiques qui
s'accumulent. Et donc c'est le premier
moteur, on va dire, de mon engagement et
c'est pour moi la plus la plus
angoissante puisque vous savez en
politique, il y a des sujets qui sont
réversibles, il y a des sujets qui sont
irréversibles.
Lesquels ? Bah, en l'occurrence la
France a pu connaître par le passé des
grandes phases d'endettement dont elle a
pu se se sortir, des périodes de
déclassement économique dont elle a su
évidemment euh ressurgir. En revanche,
la démographie c'est irréversible.
Voilà, le jour où et bien le peuple
historique d'un pays est minoritaire sur
son sol, et bien la mécanique à l'œuvre
fait que vous ne retrouverez jamais la
liberté qui était la vôtre et que demain
vous pouvez avoir un pays qui s'appelle
France he qui porte le même prénom mais
qui n'aura plus le même visage et qui
finalement sera plus le même dans son
dans son être qui demain même pourrait
être une une République française mais
une République islamique française. Et
je vous dis ça sans provocation pour des
effets tout simplement numériques.
Voilà. Donc donc pour moi c'est un sujet
central parce que c'est un sujet
irréversible et nous sommes dans une
course contre la montre démographique
nous français mais pas seulement les
Européens au sens large. Deuxème sujet
et ça je sais que ça vous tient à cœur
la question de notre indépendance et de
notre souveraineté aujourd'hui. Alors je
dirais
énergétique et industrielle alimentaire.
Exactement. Exactement. Alors sur la
souveraineté, je dirais qu'aujourd'hui
on a un phénomène qui est qui est propre
à l'ensemble de l'Occident et qui qui a
une réponse compliquée d'ailleurs qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui nous avons une
lecture de l'état de droit qui se fait
contre la démocratie. C'est la
décommocratie meurt aujourd'hui euh de
d'une lecture de l'état de droit qui
s'est transformé en gouvernement des
juges, hein, c'est-à-dire aujourd'hui
bah l'accumulation de jurisprudence à la
fois du Conseil d'État, de la cour du
Conseil constitutionnel, de la cour de
justice de de l'Union européenne, de la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
qui ont une interprétation extrêmement
extensive des textes et qui font que et
bien il contraignent le politique dans
sa prise de décision. Bah l'exemple le
plus récent, vous l'avez suivi, c'est la
censure complètement délirante du
Conseil constitutionnel sur la loi
immigration euh en expliquant par
exemple qu'il s'agissait de cavalier
législatif, donc que toutes les mesures
sur l'immigration dans la texte en fait
n'avaient rien à voir avec
l'immigration. Donc c'était des
cavaliers législatifs. Voilà. Donc on a
là pour moi l'exemple type d'une en plus
une politisation de ces de ces
juridictions
qui ont un agenda politique à eux en
l'occurrence plutôt un agenda
immigrationniste et qui donc contraign
excessivement le politique. Et c'est
vrai également du droit européen où on
s'éloigne parfois très largement des
textes et pour vous donner un exemple
aujourd'hui bah si nous voulions
supprimer le regroupement familial nous
ne pourrions plus le faire non seulement
du fait de la jurisprudence du Conseil
constitutionnel mais aussi du fait de la
du droit européen. Pourquoi ? Parce que
le les les les juges du Conseil
constitutionnel ont déduit d'un principe
constitutionnel de vie du respect de vie
privée et familiale le fait qu'on
pouvait pas toucher au regroupement
familial. Vous doutez bien que le
constituant au moment où il écrit la
constitution n'imagine pas du tout
évidemment que ce respect de la vie
privée et familiale puisse induire le
l'impossibilité de supprimer le
groupement familial.
Est-ce que vous êtes mis à la place de
la personne qui attend de revoir sa
femme ou ses enfants en France alors
qu'il bosse, il paye ses impôts, il est
tout seul,
il a sa femme au téléphone cinq fois par
jour, ses enfants lui manquent. Vous
savez, je je moi je mon cap aujourd'hui
c'est je suis une femme une responsable
politique française. Donc mon je vous
parlais de mon moteur tout à l'heure, on
va dire
femme c'est la même chose he pour nous.
Homme ou femme, c'est la même chose
responsable politique un responsable
politique, voilà, mais en l'occurrence
aussi une femme, mais voilà, une une
responsable politique française. Et donc
mon mon on parlait tout à l'heure de de
mon moteur, mais on va dire ma grille de
lecture, mon logiciel politique, c'est
d'abord et avant tout la défense des
intérêts français de de l'intégrité et
de la sécurité du pays qui est le mien
et que je vais pouvoir transmettre à mes
enfants. ça qui est qui est en
permanence le le ce ce à quoi je passe
le tami de mes idées et de mes
propositions. Donc à partir du moment où
je considère qu'aujourd'hui
l'immigration telle qu'elle s'expose à
nous, c'est-à-dire j'en ai parlé tout à
l'heure, de façon massive, de façon
incontrôlée, déconnecté des besoins
économiques du pays et de la capacité de
ce pays à pouvoir accueillir dans des
conditions dignes, et bien oui, je
considère qu'aujourd'hui le regroupement
familial euh euh alimente une politique
familiale et un accueil de de lié à la
politique familiale qui est complètement
déraisonnable et que nous n'arrivons
plus à pouvoir assumer ni sur le plan
économique, ni sur le plan culturel.
Donc je comprends ce que vous dites et
vous savez
ce que j'ai dit
quand vous disiez justement est-ce que
vous pensez à la personne qui euh c'est
c'est les les positions que je prends et
les idées que je défends ne ne sont pas
faciles à défendre. Vous savez c'est
c'est
c'est pour ça qu'on vous qualifie
d'extrême droite.
Alors je pense qui probablement alors je
pense qu'il y a derrière ça beaucoup
aussi de mauvaise fois. Je vous disais
tout à l'heure, je pense que la volonté
de disqualifier l'adversaire sur le plan
moral parce que une fois que vous avez
disqualifié l'adversaire sur le plan
moral, cela vous euh comment dire vous
dispense de répondre sur le fond puisque
comme l'autre est par essence le diable,
vous ne discutez pas avec le diable.
Donc je pense que c'est plus malhonnête
que ça et je pense que la plupart des
gens qui utilisent ce terme savent très
bien qu'il est impropre parce que
l'extrême droite à un moment donné
au-delà aujourd'hui du d'un terme
disqualifiant, ça correspond à des
critères euh politiques précis et en
l'occurrence euh notamment des courants
autoritaristes, antiparlementaristes
dans lesquels moi je ne me retrouve pas
et qui a un problème qui ne me
correspond pas. Et
autre question euh euh vous avez dit
immigration massive. Alors c'est quoi
une immigration massive et c'est quoi
une immigration pas massive
? Je réponds juste à votre question.
Euh [grognement] juste avant en vous
disant parce que parce que faut pas
croire que euh on n' pas de compassion à
l'égard des personnes. Faut pas croire
que on est tous des êtres humains
Méditerrané qui fit les dictateurs.
La torture, les génocides et
évidemment évidemment. Donc moi, je suis
pas indifférente aux personnes et à la
situation des personnes. Et croyez-moi,
les décisions qu'on prend sont des
décisions. En tout cas, le programme que
j'aimerais défendre est un programme
dont je sais qu'il est il est dur et
exigeant, mais il est nécessaire parce
que vous savez, le problème, c'est que
la solidarité euh c'est pas le suicide.
Alors et le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai envie de vous dire
si la France se portait extrêmement bien
que l'immigration posait pas de
difficultés que l'identifi
les difficultés
bah je vous en ai parlé tout à l'heure
on va les détailler mais je vous dis des
des difficultés identitair des selon moi
évidemment je parle en mon nom je vous
le confirme difficultés sécuritaires
et avérer pour le coup c'estàd que
aujourd'hui même le ministre de
l'intérieur Gérald Darmanin ne ni plus
qu'il y a un lien entre immigration et
et insécurité sûr de votre source
je suis absolument sûr de de ma source.
Je vais vous dire, il y a aujourd'hui 20
20 à 25 % des détenus dans notre pays
qui sont des personnes de nationalité
étrangère. Je parle même pas de
personnes, c'est les chiffres du
ministère de l'intérieur.
Je vous parle même pas pour le coup de
personnes d'origine étrangère, je vous
parle de personnes de nationalité
étrangère. Savoir que dans nos prisons
aujourd'hui, il y a plus de
ressortissants de nationalité algérien
que de détenus de de nationalité
européenne. Je dire à eux seuls les
algériens représentent plus de détenus
que l'ensemble des détenus étrangers de
nationalité.
Posé la question. Pourquoi ?
Ah bah je me suis posé la question
pourquoi ? Je pense qu'il y a plusieurs
facteurs mais c'est tout ça pour vous
démontrer le lien. Donc ça c'est un
premier sujet. Je pense que premier
sujet, c'est que euh un, nous avons des
personnes qui ne s'assimilent plus,
voire se désassimile, c'est dire qui ne
qui arrivent dans un pays dont ils ne se
sentent plus contraints, pardon, de
respecter à la fois euh les lois, euh le
mode de vie, voilà qui est qui sont
également qui profitent, j'ai envie de
dire, de l'effondrement de l'autorité de
l'État. Ça veut dire qu'ils ont le
sentiment aujourd'hui qu'il y a une
justice pénale qui ne fait plus son
travail, qui a un qui a un laxisme
ambiant qui bah finalement ne ne met pas
de cadre, ne met pas de limite dont ils
se sentent libre d'eux.
Troisièmement, je pense qu'il y a
aujourd'hui euh une des des cultures
d'origine qui sont parfois plus
violentes, qui s'inscrivent dans des
pays qui fonctionnent parfois de manière
plus autoritaire et qu'en important ses
cultures d'origine sur le sol français
dans un dans un environnement à la fois
légal et culturel plus permissif, et
bien évidemment bah ça ça crée des des
difficultés
quand vous dites des
d'adaptation. Et je finis juste par là
et après je vous réponds. Dernière
[grognement] chose euh
après je peux poser ma question ?
Oui oui bien sûr. Non mais c'est juste
pour aller au bout de de mon
raisonnement. Euh la [grognement]
dernière chose, c'est que je pense qu'il
y a euh vous savez, moi quand je
m'engage en politique, je j'ai j'essaie
de défendre une chose qui m'a paraît euh
la plus noble des choses et qui est un
terme aujourd'hui qui est accaparé par
la gauche, je vais vous surprendre, qui
est ce terme fraternité parce que pour
moi, il y a trois items dans notre dans
notre dans notre devise nationale. Il y
a liberté, égalité, fraternité. La
fraternité elle a une [grognement]
particularité, c'est que ça n'est pas ça
ne se décrète pas politiquement. La
liberté et l'égalité, vous pouvez
l'organiser euh politiquement.
La liberté, ça ça se prend.
Ça se prend mais ça s'organise aussi.
Vous pouvez quand même mettre un
environnement légal qui permette et
favorise la liberté. En revanche, la
fraternité, c'est un sentiment. C'est un
sentiment. C'est-à-dire que j'ai un
sentiment fraternel à l'égard de celui
dans lequel je reconnais une part de
moi. C'est c'est quelque chose
d'ailleurs les Français souvent qui sont
expatriés le ressortent de manière très
spontanée. C'est ce qui fait qu'on est
un peuple.
Alors les Français expatriés ne sont pas
un exemple. Non, mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que on le ressent plus
facilement quand on est une minorité de
français à l'étranger parce qu'on a un
sentiment fraternel parce que voilà
parce qu'on a constituer des liens un
peu immatériel parce qu'on a eu des des
comment dire ça ? On a eu des épreuves
passées, on a on a des souvenirs
communs, on a des joies communes, on a
des on a des fondations, j'ai envie de
dire moral, éthique qu'on partage de
manière spontanée. Donc ce sentiment
fraternel c'est quelque chose d'extra
extrêmement précieux parce que c'est ce
qui fait que ça crée la cohésion et la
solidarité au sein d'un peuple qui fait
qu'on se sent concerné par
l'agriculteur, par l'étudiant en
difficulté, par la personne âgée dans un
épade, même si on la connaît pas, pas la
même génération, c'est pas la même
région mais c'est mon peuple et donc
j'ai envie et je me sens concerné. Et le
problème c'est que ces personnes
aujourd'hui qui arrivent massivement sur
le sol français n'ont pas ce sentiment
fraternel à l'égard de la France euh
parce que elles sont bien souvent un
dans des environnements, on va dire de
vie dans lesquels elles ne elles ne sont
plus en condition de s'assimiler.
C'est-à-dire que pour pouvoir
s'assimiler, il faut s'assimiler à
quelqu'un, il faut s'assimiler à quelque
chose. Si vous n'êtes jamais au
quotidien en lien ou confronté à, on va
dire un français de souche qui est le
référent auquel vous êtes censé vous
assimiler, bah faut pas s'étonner que
l'assimilation fonctionne pas. Et si en
plus de ça, et je finis juste par là,
excuse-moi, je suis hyper longue, euh
[rires]
si en plus de ça, vous êtes dans un
environnement politique dont les élites
elles-même alimentent un ressentiment à
la garere de la France, euh euh comment
dire laisse entendre en permanence que
on a raison de pas aimer la France parce
que la France euh c'est la colonisation,
c'est l'esclavage, c'est le mépris ou le
racisme à l'égard des minorités, bah
évidemment, faut pas s'attendre à ce que
il y ait un sentiment fraternel. Et donc
ça bah évidemment ça détruit le civisme
et ça vous libère finalement dans vos
pulsions vis-à-vis des des Français
notamment.
Alors français de souche c'est à partir
de combien de générations qu'on est
français ? Et deuxème question vous avez
parlé de de nationalité plus j'ai pas
compris plus agressive plus violente.
Non j'ai parlé de de culture d'origine.
De culture d'origine dans lequel
évidemment il y avait dans certains
pays.
Ça c'est une étude c'est vous basez sur
quoi ?
Non mais c'est je veux dire c'est une
c'est une c'est une évidence.
C'està-dire que quand vous avez
il y a des évidences pour les uns, il y
a il y a pas d'évidence pour les autres
peut-être. Alors, ce sera mon évidence à
moi, mais de fait, vous avez des
personnes tout simplement qui arrivent
de pays qui fonctionnent de façon
autoritaire, voir semi-autoritaire, en
particulier pour l'Afrique ou le Maghreb
dans certains pays et qui arrivent dans
un environnement, je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure, légal, extrêmement permissif et
donc à partir de là, bah évidemment, ils
se sentent moins tenus qu'ils n'auraient
pu l'être dans leur pays d'origine par
habitude. Voilà. Bon, ça me paraît être
être une une évidence et on et on le
voit comme je vous le disais dans les
les taux de criminalité en particulier
chez les personnes euh de
si je me fais l'avocat du diable, c'est
une interprétation de votre part parce
que c'est multifactoriel. Bah, les
chiffres que je vous ai donnés tout à
l'heure font quand même la démonstration
que les personnes aujourd'hui euh
extraeuropéennes et très très
majoritairement venu donc d'Afrique
sub-saharienne et du Maghreb euh ont des
des taux de criminalité plus importants.
Je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure de
l'exemple euh des détenus, mais quand
vous regardez également la criminalité
des mineurs isolés dans notre pays qui
est plus élevé, on parlait on pourrait
parler par exemple des déclarations du
préfet des Alpes Maritimes qui explique
aujourd'hui 60 % du trafic de drogue à
Nice vient des des mineurs isolés. On
pourrait vous parler des chiffres qui
ont été faits par le ministère de
l'intérieur. Alors, c'est là où je vous
suis, c'est que c'est des chiffres qui
sont très limités parce que les
statistiques ethniques sont interdites
en France et que évidemment le
gouvernement fait tout pour avoir euh
euh comment dire des chiffres assez
réduits. Mais les quelques uns dont nous
disposons sont objectivement sans
équivoque. Euh quand vous voyez
aujourd'hui qu'à peu près 65 65 % des
agressions sexuelles dans les transports
en Île-de-France sont le fait de
personnes de nationalité étrangère et
très très majoritairement issu de enfin
d'origine extraeuréenne. Et il y a eu un
rapport également de police très
intéressant et un rapport de la
préfecture à l'issue des émeutes de juin
dernier pour un peu, on va dire analyser
les profils de ces de ces émetiers. Et
ce qu'il en ressortait c'est que c'était
majoritairement des majeurs d'ailleurs
plutôt contrairement à ce qu'il a pu à
dire. Il y avait des mineurs bien sûr,
mais majoritairement des majeurs, des
hommes euh et très largement également
issus de l'immigration maghrébine ou
africaine. Voilà. Bon, donc ça c'est
factuel.
Est-ce que je peux vous poser une autre
question ? Oui.
Est-ce que vous pouvez faire la critique
de vos votre propre raisonnement ?
Mais moi, je le fais tous les jours,
je peux vous dire. Moi, je je je doute.
Ça m'arrive de douter, bien sûr. Euh
d'autant plus que moi, vous avez la
remise en question, elle est permanente
puisque je fais partie quand même d'un
courant politique qui est en permanence
challengé. C'est-à-dire que quand je
vais sur un plateau de télévision, euh
[grognement] j'ai rarement quand même
des journalistes qui me déroulent le
tapis rouge, qui ne me portent pas la
contradiction, qui la contradiction, je
vous déroule pas le tapis rouge.
Mais c'est exactement, je dis pas le
contraire. Ce que je veux dire, c'est
que
change dans le respect. Mais absolument
ce que je veux dire c'est que euh moi je
je on essaie on est challengé tout le
temps et d'ailleurs je pense que je
serais fact checké et légitimement
d'ailleurs. Donc donc ne croyez pas que
je ne doute pas. Euh en tout cas, de
tout ce que je vois et tout ce que je
tout ce que je peux ressentir
instinctivement et que je vérifie,
malheureusement d'une certaine manière
se confirme dans les faits.
On passe à autre chose, on continue.
Ah ben c'est à vous de me dire hein.
Géopolitique,
on le prend sous quel angle ? On le
prend sous l'angle la France est devenue
un pays de moyenne impuissance, une
puissance de moyenne impuissance. On
prend sous le fait que
bah on parle un peu pour ne rien dire,
on est un petit peu tétanisé ou on est
très actif, on essaie de nous faire
entendre,
on le prend sous quel angle ?
Un peu tout ça.
Comment vous expliquez que en ce moment,
géopolitiquement parlant, les démons se
réveillent ?
Comment vous expliquez que on est dans
un regain de tension géopolitique qui
est maintenant ouvert ? On est passé de
la guerre économique à la guerre tout
court ?
C'est quoi votre lecture de tout ça ?
Mais
je pense que tout ça est le fruit d'un
d'un renoncement, c'est-à-dire avant
tout d'un renoncement à la puissance. Ce
terme de puissance, c'est marrant
d'ailleurs parce que c'est un terme qui
est revenu un peu au goût du jour, hein,
comme le terme de souveraineté mais qui
pendant décennies a été complètement
abandonné par les élites françaises
parce que dans le français
dans leur esprit bah les élites
françaises, les les gouvernements
successifs, les conseillers politiques
de l'époque, voilà, les têtes
d'affiches, voilà, et les et les
penseurs divers et variés qui étaient
proches du pouvoir tout simplement. Et
je pense que pour parce que je pense que
dans leur esprit, ce terme de puissance
renvoyait à la notion de compétition.
Or, [grognement] c'était pas cohérent
avec leur idée du du doux commerce.
Voilà, dans lequel la prédation n'existe
pas, la déloyauté n'existe pas. Ils
étaient extrêmement naïfs. Et puis ce
terme de de puissance pour eux, je pense
d'une certaine manière renvoie à des
formes de guerre, peut-être même de
nationalisme parce que ça veut dire que
la puissance c'est un pays qui euh sait
d'exotisme.
Ah bah pour moi c'est du patriotisme.
Mais je pense que dans leur esprit, je
me mets à la place des élites. Je pense
que ça raisonnait pour eux comme
nationalisme, donc comme guerre. Voilà.
Euh parce que l'idée de la puissance,
c'est-à-dire être capable de de projeter
son être et de défendre ses intérêts euh
à l'extérieur, pour ça encore faut-il
avoir conscience de son être euh et
savoir en définir le périmètre, savoir
d'où l'on vient. Or, pendant longtemps,
je crois que nos élites elles-mêmes
considéraient que finalement le niveau
national était un niveau dépassé.
On l'attend, on le dit comment ?
Des deux pardon
de se connaître soi-même.
Ah, de se Je sais pas, vous avez une
civilisation latine à me à me donner.
Non, pas du tout. En fait, j'ai un
éclair de lucidité mais j'arrive pas à
l'attraper hein.
Ouais. Les années de latin, ça ça date
là. Ouais. Vous avez fait grec ou latin
? Ben
moi, j'ai fait les deux, mon capitaine,
mais peu de temps et j'étais et j'étais
nul en grec ancien. En l'occurrence,
j'ai fait la majorité de ma scolarité en
public, mais j'ai fait 2 ans en privé et
ces 2 ans c'est là où j'ai fait du latin
et du grec. Donc vous voyez, j'ai en
plus pas pas [grognement] beaucoup de
pratique. Euh et pour vous répondre donc
sur la la question de la géopolitique,
donc je pense que ça part d'un
renoncement d'abord donc à penser la
puissance et à vouloir la puissance tout
simplement. Qu'est-ce
qu'il fallait faire ?
Bah sur le plan diplomatique déjà, il va
falloir acter une chose, c'est que euh
l'armée est précisément le bras armé de
la diplomatie.
Quelle armée, l'armée économique ou
l'armée ?
Alors là, je parle de l'armée au sens de
la défense. C'està-dire que pour avoir
une diplomatie qui soit forte et
entendue, faut aussi avoir les moyens de
sa diplomatie. Donc faut avoir un réseau
diplomatique mais il faut aussi avoir
euh si je peux dire les arguments qui
vont derrière pour être pris au sérieux
et en renonçant justement à des
investissements de défense, à des
recherches en matière de défense, à des
à des à des matériels suffisants et
innovants pendant une fois de plus des
années parce qu'on commence seulement à
rehausser les budgets de la défense mais
pendant des années ça a été la variable
d'ajustement de la dette. On préférait
faire du social. Voilà. [grognement]
Et bien on a
Tu peux me faire l'invoquer du diable ?
Allez-y, vous faites ça très bien.
[rires]
Si
vis pasem par belhomme. Si vispassem
parapassem. [grognement]
Oui, mais en fait
le fait de déposer les armes pour
montrer aux autres qu'on devient une
société pacifiste,
est-ce que les autres les ont déposé ?
Ah bah ça, est-ce qu'on avait les les
yeux et les oreilles pour comprendre ?
Bah c'est ça en fait le problème, c'est
que c'est très charmant sur le papier.
Mais si tu veux, la paix prépare la
guerre, c'est ce que font toutes les
nations depuis toujours. Ça veut pas
dire qu'on veut utiliser les armes. Ça
veut pas.
Est-ce que vous pensez que la paix est
au bout d'un fusil ? Je pense qu'en tout
cas euh le fusil au au pied est quand
même la dissuasion de celui d'en face
qui pourrait avoir la tentation de
l'utiliser contre vous. Voilà. Donc ça
ne veut pas dire qu'on souhaite
l'utiliser mais c'est évidemment une
protection. Alors après toujours pareil
hein, tout dépend du présupposé dont on
parle y compris sur le plan
philosophique vis-à-vis de l'humain.
Est-ce que l'humain est un loup pour
l'homme ou est-ce que on est rouiste ?
Oh je toutes les sétati je me souviens
plus.
Oui oui.
Allez-y étalez-moi votre science. C'est
[rires] pas ma sance. Vous
s même pas au bout en plus.
Donc euh est-ce que
ça finit par l'eau pousseste ?
Voilà, c'est ça. C'est quelque chose
comme ça. [rires]
Mais non, mais très sérieusement, je
pense que derrière ça, quand on revient
aux sources, il y a un vrai présupposé
philosophique et et je pense qu'on
l'erreur est là. Euh on est pris, les
français, on adore conceptualiser, mais
il y a il y a voilà, est-ce que l'homme
est un loup pour l'homme ou est-ce que
euh finalement euh euh c'est et c'est
donc c'est la société qui va euh faire
en sorte que euh l'homme devienne
mauvaise à partir d'une nature qui est
bonne. et ces deux présuposés là où
est-ce que l'homme est un animal
politique ? Enfin, tous ces présupposés
font que est-ce qu'on considère
finalement que l'homme est bon par
nature et que c'est la société,
l'organisation de la société qui le rend
mauvais ou est-ce qu'on considère que
l'homme a des vis intraseques et qu'il a
des pulsions naturelles et que bah ça
c'est c'est envie de dire indépassable.
Et donc le rôle de la civilisation,
c'est de canaliser ses pulsions et ses
vis indépassables. Moi, j'ai tendance à
considérer que oui, il y a du il y a du
mal en l'homme et que bah le le la
violence, elle existe et elle existera
toujours. Et je pense que
voilà, pendant longtemps, les élites ont
considéré que bah finalement l'homme
était par essence bon, que c'était la
société qui le pervertissait et que donc
il suffisait d'organiser une grande
ronde mondiale avec l'OMC et l'économie
pour que voilà finalement tout se passe
bien. Sauf que bah le tragique est
revenu à nos portes y compris jusqu'en
Europe. Et donc on se réveille de façon
brutale, comme à chaque fois comme on
s'est réveillé de façon extrêmement
brutale sur le Covid avec toutes nos
dépendances industrielles et et
médicamente et donc la question
maintenant c'est savoir est-ce qu'on va
être capable d'en tirer les conclusions
et pas trop tard quoi.
Si c'est trop tard, on est condamné à
quoi ?
Sauf que moi je ne pense pas que ce soit
trop tard. Enfin en tout cas je je
l'espère et je ne le pense pas. Je crois
que la France a encore des des des
atouts euh [grognement] mais je crois
que
bah je crois qu'elle elle dispose en
malgré tout d'un alors déjà elle est
quand même prise au sérieux par un
certain nombre quand même de d'alliés et
dans le dans le dans le de le on va dire
dans la compétition mondiale elle est
quand même une puissance militaire alors
une puissance militaire moyenne vous
avez raison par rapport à la Chine et
par rapport aux États-Unis mais quand
même
3 4 jours de capacité en cas de guerre
de haute intensité
vous avez raison et c'est en train
laborieusement d'être laborieusement
d'être d'être corrigé. Néanmoins, on
reste quand même, je mets l'Angleterre
de côté au sein de l'Union européenne,
la plus grande armée, la seule de
pouvoir capable pouvoir se projeter à
l'extérieur. On est une malgré tout une
puissance nucléaire. Maintenant, je
pense que pour vous parler franchement,
la France a perdu aussi et de son
prestige et de son audience parce
qu'elle n'a pas su garder sa singularité
aussi diplomatique. C'est-à-dire que je
crois, je continue de penser d'ailleurs
que l'horizon
indépassable de la France n'est pas
l'Europe. C'est aussi l'Europe mais ça
n'est pas que l'Europe. Or, les élites
françaises ces dernières des années en
se en se s'enfermant dans l'obsession de
la construction européenne, je pense
réduit l'horizon français et on
réduit dissous ou délayé.
Alors après, on parlera de la
construction de l'Union européenne en
tant que telle, mais je pense qu'elles
ont réduit l'horizon français.
C'est-à-dire que dorén avant, on
considérait que bah l'horizon
diplomatique de la France et son énergie
devait être consacré uniquement aux
relations intraeuropéennes et je pense
au détriment d'autres parties du monde.
Je pense notamment à l'Amérique latine
alors que nous avons bah du fait de
territoire guyanais une présence qui
aurait pu justifier que nous puissions
avoir un vrai une vraie présence là-bas.
Je pense évidemment à nos territoires
euh réunionnais et et Maoré qui nous
donne également une présence dans cette
zone du monde qui devient de plus en
plus centrale et déterminante et sur
lequel on a petit à petit abandonné des
moyens. Je pense pas Saint-Pierre et
Michelon s'il vous plaît.
Tout à fait. On pourrait aussi parler
des relations avec l'Inde. Voilà. Donc,
il y a beaucoup de choses qui font que
on s'est on a réduit notre horizon et
puis on s'est aligné pour parler
franchement aussi sur bah une une grille
de lecture américaine pour faire simple.
Et donc bah pendant longtemps, la France
c'était quoi ? La France était le pays
qui était au milieu, c'est-à-dire qui
défendait les petits pays contre l'abus
des grandes puissances. Et donc c'est ça
qui fait que nous avions un prestige
certain auprès de ce qu'on appelle
notamment aujourd'hui le sud global et
qui
un prestige ou un soft power.
un prestige et un soft power parce que
les deux vont ensemble hein. Je dire la
perte du prestige, on l'a vu en Afrique
très douloureusement. Bah elle s'est
payée quand même par un sentiment entre
français qui fait qu'on a fini par se
faire. Russ et les Chinois nous ont un
peu aidé quand même.
Ah mais bien sûr, mais ils ont ils ont
flirté et alimenté évidemment un oui une
une perte de prestige qui qui est liée
je pense à des défaillances
diplomatiques et et géopolitiques. Donc
tout ça pour dire qu'aujourd'hui on a
renseignement
aussi mais là une fois plus naïveté.
Naïveté sur
naïveté ou incompétence.
Probablement les deux. Probablement les
deux. Parfois on vous savez faut se
méfier parce que parfois on a toujours
le sentiment que il y a des grands plans
ou des grandes idéologies ou des choses
très construites et en fait très souvent
bah vous avez raison ça en revient à ça
c'est de la naïveté et de l'incompétence
tout simplement ou [grognement]
simplement des acquis c'estàd que les
gens s'appuyent sur leurs acquis voilà
la France ça a été ça donc c'était
facile on faisait comme si c
s'app ou s'endort
s'appuie ou s'endor sur ses acquis oui
c'est ça c'est-à-dire que on avait des
atouts. On considérait que bah ces
atouts ils étaient là à Vitam et
Eternam. Voilà en latin à Vitam eternam
pas mal. [grognement] Et c'était
lesquels les atou ? C'était la
francophonie
le fran CFA
et notamment des des relations en effet
économique privilégié avec avec
l'Afrique. On était des interlocuteurs
prioritaires voire exclusifs sur
certains sujets et puis on a considéré
que ça c'était naturel et que c'était
acquis. Sauf qu'entre-temps bah la
Turquie est arrivée, la Chine est
arrivée, les Américains sont arrivés
[grognement] ils avaient des choses
peut-être plus intéressant à proposer
que nous. payent plus où ils sont plus
investis à construire des routes, des
hôpitaux, à essayer de projeter, faire
des accords de coopération et avoir un
dialogue franc. Et nous, on partait avec
la France-Afrique un peu la la même
politique que les États-Unis ont eu en
Amérique.
Je pense qu'ils ont réussi des moyens
enfin quand on regarde aujourd'hui ce
que propose la Chine aux africains
notamment en terme de capacité d'emprunt
évidemment voilà de crédit euh c'est
évidemment des moyens queon pas
peut-être ou pas voulu ou pas su mettre
sur la table. Je pense aussi qu'on a
fait une erreur parce que tous ces pays
quand ils arrivent en Afrique, ils le
font aussi pour installer leurs propres
puissances économiques et donc il
favorise aussi leur société sur place.
Et nous on a voulu faire du saupoudrage,
on a voulu faire de l'aide au
développement sans véritable vision,
sans véritable cohérence. Donc le
résultat c'est que non seulement on
éétait pas efficace mais en plus on a
perdu des points sur nos entreprises
présentes sur place à force de pas
vouloir les favoriser par rapport aux
autres. Et donc bah petit à petit ça a
été de la perte d'influence, du recul
jusqu'à ce qu'on fasse prendre les
marchés euh et voilà. Donc tout ça pour
dire que oui, il y a aujourd'hui une
situation compliquée mais qui pour moi
n'est pas totalement inexorable si
tentez qu'on se réveille à temps.
Si d'un coup un coup de baguette
magique, je vous bombarde présidente de
la France ou premier ministre ou
ministre des affaires étrangères.
Oui.
Votre première décision à l'étranger,
c'est de faire quoi ?
Alors déjà bah typiquement pour
rebondir, on pourrait imaginer que
aujourd'hui l'aide française au
développement
soit toujours faite en coordination
prioritaire avec nos entreprises sur
place. C'est-à-dire queon peut allier
les deux à la fois nos intérêts
économiques, les parts de marché de nos
sociétés et en même temps évidemment le
développement des des territoires. Donc
ça ça me permet être une une première
chose. Je pense que euh moi je vais vous
dire je pense qu'on va payer je fais une
petite digression mais qui va me
permettre de répondre à votre question.
[grognement] Je pense qu'on va payer
très durement ce conflit
russo-ukrainien. Je crois que on se rend
pas encore compte qu'on a changé de
monde et malheureusement en ce qui
concerne en est arrivé là.
Je pense qu'il y a eu euh des
irresponsabilités
de qui
partagé. [grognement] Euh je pense qu'on
aurait pu éviter ce conflit. Voilà, je
vous le dis, je pense qu'on aurait pu
l'éviter. Euh je pense qu'on aurait pu
l'éviter notamment en faisant appliquer
les fameux accords de Minsk hein qui
n'ont pas été appliqués. Budapest, il
fallait les faire accorder, les faire
respecter aussi.
Oui, mais je pense que je pense que le
problème, c'est que on a à un moment
donné on a laissé aussi les Américains
euh étendre de manière, me semble-t-il,
irresponsable l'OTAN. [grognement] On
savait que les Russes avaient pour ligne
rouge, pour le coup, ils s'en étaient
pas cachés, hein, l'Ukraine. Voilà.
[grognement]
Euh je crois que l'Ukraine ne pouvait
pas être seul décisionnaire évidemment
de son intégration à l'OTAN ou de sa
nucléarisation puisqueà un moment donné
ce débat est arrivé puisque évidemment
de la de la de la neutralité de
l'Ukraine dépendait l'intégralité de la
sécurité du continent et là je trouve
que la France n'a pas joué son rôle à ce
moment-là c'est dire que la France
aurait dû faire partie de ceux qui
refusaient l'extension de longtemps pour
des raisons de sécurité liée à à bah la
sécurité du continent et aurait dû
quand même goler la Crimée les Russes.
Non mais bien sûr. Non mais c'est pour
ça que je vous dis il y a des
responsabilités partagées
puisqueévidemment chacun a joué ses
jeux. On sait très bien que il y a eu
des des influences pour que certains
gouvernements soient mis en place en
Ukraine et les Russes ont joué à ça
avant ça. Donc de toute façon, ça a
toujours été une zone évidemment dans
lequelle se jouait des conflits
d'influence entre les Américains et les
Ukrainiens. Mais la question c'est
les Russes
et qu'est-ce que j'ai dit ? Et oui, les
Russes. Oui, vous avez raison. Donc la
question c'est que je trouve que la
France aurait dû à ce moment-là si elle
avait voulu éviter ce conflit euh mettre
un stop à cette espèce de de comment
dire de fuite en avant parce que bah ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est que donc
on a laissé se mettre en place un
conflit dont la Russie a été finalement
le le déclencheur en violation du droit
international et en déclenchant cette
guerre. Mais dont la conclusion c'est
quoi ? c'est qu'on a créé donc une
alliance aujourd'hui extrêmement solide
et puis publique et officielle entre la
Russie puissance nucléaire, la Chine
puissance nucléaire, l'Iran, puissance
nucléaire en phase de lettre en tout cas
la Corée du Nord,
puissance nucléaire avec derrière eux et
bien bah la constitution d'un bloc alors
peut-être moins caricatural que ce qu'on
en dit, c'est-à-dire le sud global parce
qu'il y a des exceptions avec l'Inde et
d'autres, mais en tout cas un bloc
antioccidental
extrêmement fort.
Voilà. Donc qu'est-ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui ? Il y a deux options.
Soit on on puisque plus le temps passe,
plus le temps sert la Russie.
Manifestement de ce qu'on voit sur le
terrain relativement au conflit. À
partir du moment où les Américains ont
dit "On n'enverra pas d'hommes sur
place" que les Européens eux-mêmes et je
pense à raison ne veulent pas envoyer
d'hommes sur place parce qu'ils veulent
pas être en guerre avec une puissance
nucléaire. Voilà. Donc ils le font de
manière détournée. Les ressources
humaines de l'Ukraine, c'est déjà un
massacre, disons-le, ne sont pas euh
inexpensible. Sauf qu'en parallèle, bah
vous avez pour le coup un pays qui a des
ressources plus importantes. Donc
maintenant, c'est une situation terrible
parce que évidemment on ne veut pas que
l'Ukraine perde parce que il en va bah
du respect de ces territoires et si
l'Ukraine perd aujourd'hui, on est allé
tellement loin dans l'application dans
le conflit que c'est nous qui perdons,
c'est l'Europe qui perd. Et donc si
l'Europe perd, vous imaginez le signal
que ça envoie à toutes ces puissances et
à toutes ces puissances émergentes qui
pourront se sentir les mains totalement
libres sur aujourd'hui des conflits
territoriaux et géographiques. On peut
par exemple Taiïwan en Chine. Qu'est-ce
qui retient aujourd'hui ces pays ? C'est
de se dire bah peut-être que si on y va,
c'est pas dit quand même que le bloc
occidental si là on perd c'est quand
même la démonstration qu'ils sont plus
forts que nous. Donc ça c'est
Taiwan c'est une île et Taiwan c'est la
Suisse en terme de défense.
Non c'est pas ce que je veux dire. Je
parle de du de du la potentialité pour
la Chine de vouloir récupérer ce
territoire avec la nécessité.
Bon courage.
Mais ce que ce que je veux vous dire,
c'est que je pense que jusqu'ici tant
que ce conflit n'est pas perdu, la Chine
peut toujours se dire "Ah quand même le
bloc occidental en face c'est pas
simple. En tout cas les États-Unis là
aujourd'hui si on perd c'est terrible.
Si on livre un million de drones aux
Ukrainiens,
c'est quand même efficace. 1 million de
drones c'est pas 1 million d'obus qu'on
a pas été foutu de les pondres d'en
pondre pendant un an. On en a livré
combien ? Le problème c'est les hommes.
Mais il faut il faut un mec derrière des
hommes. Le problème c'est qu'à mondé
c'est là on est vraiment sur une guerre
j'ai envie de dire c'est pas uniquement
une guerre technologique. Voilà, c'est
vraiment aussi une guerre de tranchée.
On le voit d'ailleurs avec ces images où
on gagne 5 km, 10 km. Voilà. Et le
problème c'est que c'est les hommes.
Donc moi j'ai tendance à penser que on
ne prenons pas le risque de perdre parce
que moi je ne souhaite pas cette
défaite. Je pense qu'elle serait
terrible y compris pour pour l'Europe et
en terme de signal en terme de
d'équilibre géopolitique à l'avenir.
Donc c'est j'ai envie poussons à la
négociation tant qu'il est encore temps
de négocier. Parce que si demain nous
laissons le temps passer et que
l'Ukraine aboutit à une victoire totale
bon bah là pour le coup
la Russie
qu'est-ce que je dis l'Ukraine ? Oui la
Russie. Je sais pas pourquoi je dis
l'Ukraine en permanence. Oui,
excusez-moi.
C'est peut-être un acte manqué, c'est ça
?
Non, la Russie, bien sûr. La Russie,
évidemment. La Russie.
Et négocier quoi ? [grognement]
Bah, négocier ce qui peut-être négocié,
c'est-à-dire d'une part la paix.
Et bah les J'imagine que les Russes
voudront la neutralité de l'Ukraine,
c'est qu'ils voudront que l'Ukraine
renonce à intégrer l'OTAN. Et j'imagine
que l'Ukraine voudra récupérer une
partie de ses territoires. Moi, j'ai pas
je je veux dire, j'ai pas moi, j'ai pas
le comment dire la prétention de pouvoir
vous dire euh ce qui peut être obtenu ou
pas obtenu. Ce que je suis en train de
vous dire, c'est attention à ce jusqu'au
bouthisme guerrier. On a une Commission
européenne qui a été très très active
également dans cette diplomatie
guerrière. vouloir faire des
provocations, aller de plus en plus loin
parce que je vous dis si vraiment
tu fais l'avocat du diable en face ils
sont pointés premier jour avec 250000
hommes,
ils sont allés quand même un peu fort
quand même non ?
Ah non mais je fais plus je je suis pas
là du tout pour dire que je défends la
Russie c'était pas du tout mon propos.
Ce que je suis en train de vous dire,
c'est que à un moment donné, si vous
voulez voulez faire la guerre, bah vous
en donnez les moyens. Mais la réalité,
c'est qu'on a fait le truc à moitié.
C'est-à-dire que moi je voulais je
voulais pas qu'on fasse cette guerre.
Donc je vais voilà, je dire faut être
cohérent. Dire que vous voulez la
guerre, vous faites du jusqu'au
bouhisme. Vous allez
provoquer, faire des déclarations
extrêmement violentes. On s'en souvient.
OK. Mais dans ce cas-là, bah on se
souvient qu'Usula Vlon a tenu des propos
quand même et que j'ai plus le j'ai plus
le détail, mais elle avait tenu des
propos extrêmement béliqueux à l'égard.
Le mer quand il s'était fait mettre à sa
place par Medved Medvedev concernant la
guerre économique, il avait dit quoi
déjà ?
Je me suis pas
c'était une histoire de genou d'économie
à genou un truc comme ça. Non,
je me su pas.
Nous allons mettre l'économie russe à
genou.
Oui, voilà. Nous allons mettre
l'économie russe à genou. Donc je veux
dire à un moment donné si vous voulez
faire la guerre face à une puissance
nucléaire déjà voilà bah dans ce cas-là
il faut s'en donner les moyens. Or là
l'Europe fournit du matériel mais
n'envoie pas d'homme parce que personne
veut aller faire la guerre véritablement
avec la Russie. Donc résultat, on se met
en situation de perdre avec donc toutes
les conséquences géopolitiques et en
plus on découvre des choses parce qu'en
fait c'est ce que je vous disais, on est
plus dans le même monde. C'està-dire
qu'aujourd'hui on on comprend des choses
qu'on avait qu'on avait minoré.
C'est-à-dire que finalement l'économie
russe qu'on pensait faible a beaucoup
mieux tenu qu'on l'imaginait.
Ils sont passés en économie de guerre,
c'est normal. Oui, mais ils ont quand
même su contourner des sanctions de plus
en plus fortes.
Il s'était entraîné bien avant
en imaginant Exactement. En imaginant
que justement
bah vous avez rappelé les propos à
l'instant en se disant que l'Europe
pensant ou ayant la prétention
d'imaginer qu'il pourrait les mettre à
genou et à l'inverse on a peut-être
surestimé la capacité militaire qui
existe mais qui a été moins
spectaculaire que ce à quoi on
s'attendait. C'est vrai que à un moment
donné, on s'est dit Russie Ukraine, bon
bah ça va être plié en 3 jours. Bon, ça
a pas été le cas.
Pourquoi ?
Pourquoi ? Moi je suis pas une
parce qu'ils ont pas envoyé l'avgation
avec des tapis de bombe comme les
Américains ont fait en Irak.
Je suis pas je suis pas une stratège
militaire donc j'ai pas le j'ai pas le
détail. En tout cas, tout ce que je peux
noter, c'est la surprise générale. Tout
le monde a trouvé quand même que les
Ukrainiens, et ça pour le coup, on peut
leur accorder une chose, bah la bravoure
aussi de des soldats et de la population
ukrainienne qui ont qui ont mieux tenu
et puis manifestement, je moi je je lis
ça et je regarde ça de loin, mais des
des commandements
russes qui ont été un peu à côté de la
plaque au début. Donc en tout cas, tout
ça pour vous dire quoi ? que là
typiquement on a un exemple d'un moment
où la France aurait pu aurait dû jouer
un rôle quand il en était encore temps
et au lieu de ça bah ce qui s'est
complètement aligné sur sur bah la
[raclement de gorge] grille de lecture
américaine se jetant Corséam dans dans
ce dans ce conflit euh avec la
conséquence que bah si demain ce conflit
est perdu, bah la France enraement les
conséquences et et au-delà de la France
les Ukrainiens
en payons le en paye et en payant le
prix de manière euh atroce.
Et
la France va payer comment si l'Ukraine
perd ?
bah, elle va se retrouver sans plus
aucune capacité de dialogue entre le
nord et le sud, ce qui a été notamment
sa force pendant longtemps justement
parce que la France c'était ce qu'on
disait cette puissance intermédiaire
qui était capable de parler à des pays
auxquels d'autres n'étaient pas capables
de parler parce que la France était
considérée comme un pays, je dirais pas
un pays en tout cas non aligné, en tout
cas plus indépendant euh [grognement]
voilà qui était capable de dire non à la
guerre en Irak, qui était pas totalement
aligné justement sur bah la grille de
lecture américaine qui était capable de
défendre ses propres intérêts et et
d'avoir
oui une lecture des choses qui étaient
qui qui lui étaiit singulière euh
et et là aujourd'hui malheureusement
tout ça on le voit dans le conflit entre
l'Arménie et l'Azer Azerbaïdjan France
était attendue. La voix de la France a
été attendue et elle elle n'a pas été là
au-delà de quelques petites déclarations
d'amour à l'égard de l'Arménie.
On voit bien que bah le les intérêts
gaziers qui son en fait souvent du gaz
russe d'ailleurs qui passent par la pjan
a prévalu sur tout le reste et là on n
pas entendu la France. Voilà.
Qui c'est qui a fait péter Nord Stream
selon vous ?
Bah je sais pas plus que vous hein. Je
sais pas plus que vous en tout cas moi
je regarde toujours qui a qui a intérêt.
Voilà. Alors, il y avait il y a deux
intérêts. Soit on se dit c'est les
Russes mais bon, j'ai quand même
tendance à penser que si ça avait été
les Russes, on l'aurait su quand même
surtout au regard des enquêtes qui ont
été faites. Les Russes en se disant en
disant, c'est ça
non ? Mais en plus, il y a eu quand même
des enquêtes en cours. C'est soit c'est
les Russes et avec l'idée de se dire bah
on va faire croire que ce sont les
autres et donc on va diviser les
Européens sur le sujet parce que les
Allemands vont extrêmement mal le
prendre. Voilà, on pourrait imaginer ça.
Euh soit
il voulait pas payer les amendes.
Oui, il voulait pas payer les amendes.
Exactement. Soit bon bah c'est américain
ou allié en se disant bah on coupe ou
ukrainien ou ukrainien. Mais j'ai pas
ça, j'ai pas la réponse définitive. En
tout cas, ce qui est sûr, c'est que euh
pendant des années euh les Américains ne
voulaient pas euh de ce gazoduc. On en a
assez peu parlé, c'est assez
intéressant, mais il y a eu des
manœuvres américaines incroyables pour
faire céder l'Allemagne. On va pas
revenir dessus, mais l'Allemagne avait
tenu d'ailleurs.
C'était un signal faible que les
États-Unis essayaient d'envoyer
l'Allemagne pour éviter de se mettre
sous le jour russe ou c'était simplement
pour pouvoir éviter le rapprochement
Allemagne-Russie ou c'était ou c'était
pour simplement pouvoir nous refourguer
le leur leur gaz naturel ? B je pense je
pense que c'était pour éviter évidemment
enfin tout est lié d'ailleurs le
rapprochement Allemagne Russie enfin ça
pour le coup moi j'invente pas la poudre
he il suffit de relire le grand
échiquier de Brzinski tout est dedans.
Tout est dedans et tout est d'actualité
hein sur le fait que pour bah garder une
influence forte sur l'Europe, il faut
que la Russie et l'Europe de l'Ouest
soient plutôt séparé et que un continent
eurasiatique uni et en bonne entente
serait évidemment une concurrence.
Voilà. Alors après tout tout est jamais
aussi simple évidemment puisque il y a
des il y a des il y a des intérêts des
deux côtés et tout mais en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est que bah la conclusion
aujourd'hui c'est que nous on est le
premier importateur
de gaz de GLL américain euh les chiffres
Ah j'ai [grognement] pas les chiffres en
tête j'ai juste vérifié ça vous pourrez
vérifier qu'en France on est on est le
premier importateur en Europe de GLN
américain donc c'est vrai que les les
les bah la demande a augmenté et a
explosé donc donc voilà Maintenant, à
nous de trouver l'équilibre entre bah la
nécessité de garder les Américains en
alliés parce qu'ils sont des alliés
mais d'être capable Alliance veut pas
dire fusion. Voilà. Alliance veut pas
dire fusion.
Vaut mieux un bon ennemi ou un mauvais
allié.
allié. Bah poser comme ça, je veux dire
un bon ennemi, c'est mieux parce qu'on
l'a bien identifié.
Mais après, soyons pas non plus
caricaturaux. C'est-à-dire que en fait
c'est moi qui
pas du tout, pas du tout, jamais.
Attention, je vais m'énerver,
jamais, jamais, jamais. Euh non, je ce
que je veux dire, c'est que aujourd'hui,
bon en fait aujourd'hui on a deux blocs
qui se dessinent aujourd'hui pour faire
simple. Donc on va dire le le bloc
occidental pour caricaturer aujourd'hui
dans laquelle la France est totalement
intégrée et puis le le fameux bloc
russeau chinois,
les méchants.
Les méchants comme voilà et donc
les gentils contre les méchants là.
Non, c'est jamais les gentils contre les
méchants en fait. C'est sinon si on
raisonne comme ça, on raisonne de
manière morale et donc on est à côté de
la plaque. Non, ce que je veux dire,
c'est que on peut dire qu'on ne veut pas
être ni dans un bloc ni dans l'autre, ça
veut pas dire qu'on est àidistance des
deux blocs. On peut quand même être plus
proche d'un bloc que de l'autre. Ça veut
dire que même quand de Gaulle euh refuse
d'être totalement aligné sur les
MAricains face à l'Union
Soci-soviétique, finalement il dialogue
avec les deux et pour autant il dit
évidemment qu'il se sent plus proche des
Américains sur plein de sujets, y
compris pour des raisons
civilisationnelles. Donc
ça nous a pas empêché les deux blocs de
nous des espions un peu partout
que ce soit le KGB ou la CIA.
Oui mais ça ça existera toujours et et
on et on l'a peut-être fait aussi donc
donc [rires]
voilà. Donc dernière fois c'était Mat.
Ouais mais oui mais donc ça ça existera
toujours. Et donc ça c'est les ça c'est
les règles du jeu. En tout cas voilà ce
que je veux ce que je veux dire c'est
que euh il s'agit pas de couper les
ponts avec tout le monde, il s'agit
juste de savoir être de pas être naïf y
compris avec ses alliés.
Alors là, je vais vous poser une
question vachement difficile. Une
question que personne a réussi à
résoudre depuis les 40 ou 50 dernières
années.
Rien que ça.
Ouais.
Le tout en 1h45. [rires]
Vas-y, envoie les menottes. On va la
garder un peu plus longtemps.
Le conflit arolo palestinien ont fait
quoi ? Il y a un génocide, ils sont en
train de se faire pousser au sud, ça
continue de bombarder. C'est pas un
génocide, c'est une c'est une réponse
normale d'une armée normale humaine.
C'est une réponse à des crimes du Hamas,
à un massacre du Hamas. C'est c'est
alors
on fait quoi ? Shirak, il aurait fait
quoi ? Shirak. Check il leur fait il
aurait dit quoi ? You want me to come
back into my plane
essayons essayons justement de sortir de
laffect et de de regarder ça avec avec
Est-ce qu'il faut une force
d'interposition ? Est-ce qu'il faut
qu'on se déploie ? Envoyer des casques
bleus des casques bleus en des casques
je je pense que la France doit pas
entrer dans dans ce conflit maintenant
deux choses. Bon quels sont les buts de
guerre d'Israël ? Ils s'en sont pas
cachés. Ils disent "On veut récupérer
nos otages et on veut détruire le
Hamas." Bon moi côté français je je
partage ces buts de guerre si je peux
dire. D'autant plus qu'on a des otages à
nous.
et que le Hamas aujourd'hui n'est pas
seulement une menace existentielle pour
Israël, mais est devenue dans ses dans
ces euh ramification islamiste une
menace y compris pour l'Europe et pour
la France. Preuve en est d'ailleurs à la
suite bah vous l'avez certainement suivi
bah du massacre du 7 octobre. C'était un
carnage. Et vous avez eu les images les
images sont euh
du concert des pauvres momes qui sont
elles sont insoutenables. Elles sont
insoutenables.
Vous avez vu aussi les les pauvres momes
palestiniens réduits en en toute façon
c'est c'est insoutenable des deux côtés,
c'est évident. Maintenant juste pour
vous répondre donc euh comment dire on a
du coup on fait perdre le fil. Oui. Donc
les deux buts de guerre donc on a
détruire répubèr les otages détruire le
Hamas. Aujourd'hui, le Hamas
pendant longtemps, la cause
palestinienne était une cause
nationaliste, laïque avec donc des
exigences enf en tout cas des buts de
guerre qui étaient d'ordre géographique
si je peux dire et territoriaux plutôt.
De quoi ? Les buts du Hamas,
le le but de la cause palestinienne.
Ah oui, il veut détruire complètement
Israël.
Oui, bien sûr. Bien sûr. C'est
exactement ce que je veux dire. Mais
sauf qu'aujourd'hui, il y a une mutation
de cette cause dite palestinienne et qui
aujourd'hui est totalement captée
évidemment par le Hamas et largement
soutenu par la population. Ça veut dire
que d'une cause
nationale, territoriale et au départ
laïque dans ce courant, on est on a
basculé vers un djihadisme mondial dont
la la destruction d'Israël et la défense
de la cause palestinienne est une des
composantes. Donc c'est une menace pour
nous tous. Euh et c'est là où je voulais
en venir. À la suite du massacre du
carnage, vous avez raison, du 7 octobre,
euh le condateur, l'un des cfondateurs
du Hamas fait un appel au djihad
international qui se finit en assassinat
Dominique Bernard en France. Donc je
veux dire, on a euh une menace
d'attentat avec pareil euh des membres
du Hamas en Allemagne qui ont été
arrêtés euh euh juste à temps. Donc
c'est c'est aujourd'hui diffus et c'est
c'est ambiant. Donc tout ça pour dire
que les buts de guerre, je les comprends
et du point de vue des intérêts
français, pour le coup, ils vont plutôt
dans le sens d'intérêt. Maintenant, on
peut être d'accord avec les buts de
guerre et interroger la stratégie
militaire. Moi aujourd'hui, je vous le
dis franchement, j'ai pas les
compétences pour pouvoir vous dire euh
si euh l'armée israélienne fait
exactement ce qui doit être fait pour
limiter les morts civiles euh avec les
contingences qui sont les leurs,
c'est-à-dire évidemment à Hamas qui
utilise les populations palestiniennes,
y compris les enfants, les hôpitaux, les
mosquées, on le sait, euh comme euh
voilà euh parapluie pour euh pour se
protéger.
Ça vous dit quelque chose l'arithmé
l'arithmétique de la de la rébellion ?
Non, c'est quoi ? En gros, vous vous
butez un terroriste, vous butez un
salot et mais le problème c'est que les
10 à côté, ils se transforment aussi en
terroristes parce que c'est soit le
cousin, soit la fille, soit ça fait ça
fait 10 de plus.
Le problème si vous voulez, c'est que
alors déjà euh une fois de plus, moi je
crois pas à l'intention génocidaire
d'Israël. Ça, j'y crois pas du tout. Je
pense pas que Israël tue volontairement
des civils. Je vois pas l'intérêt en
plus y compris même géopolitique qu'ils
auraient. Parce que s'ils font ça et on
le voit bien d'ailleurs, la communauté
internationale se se retourne contre eux
et ils perdent des appuis, ils perdent
des soutiens. Donc je trouve que ce
serait un
c'est peut-être pas leur intention mais
la méthode quand même c'est un peu
Non mais c'est pour ça que je vous dis
queon peut partager les les buts de
guerre et interroger la stratégie
militaire. Mais une fois de plus, je
franchement là pour le coup j'av j'
j'avoue humblement que enfin d'ailleurs
je pense que personne a vraiment tous
les éléments pour pouvoir dire oui ils
font exactement ce qu'il faut ou c'est
n'importe quoi. Voilà. La conséquence,
elle est terrible, c'est qu'il y a des
morts civiles et évidemment c'est
détestable et regrettable. Et en même
temps, je peux pas empêcher Israël et je
peux pas délégitimer Israël dans sa
réponse. Je veux dire, on aurait vécu ça
en France, qu'aurions-nous fait ? Ça me
paraît logique. Je veux dire, quand
quand vous avez des otages, quand vous
avez eu ces ces massacres, ces enfants,
ces femmes violées que vous ripostiez.
Si Israël n'avait rien fait, bon ben ça
voulait dire que le Hamas pouvait
recommencer. Voilà. Donc moi je vous je
veux dire je je ça fait comme vous
disiez plus de 76 ans qu'on a pas la
réponse. Je fais partie de ceux qui ont
défendu le principe pendant longtemps
d'une solution à deux état pensant que
c'était aussi le meilleur moyen, y
compris de défendre l'intégrité d'Israël
puisque finalement ça officialisait, ça
structurait un état donc c'était plus
facile. Je me fais l'avocater du diable
défendre aussi l'intégrité de la
Palestine
et du coup aussi de en tout cas des des
populations civiles palestiniennes he
qui aujourd'hui évidemment vivent dans
des conditions extrêmement précaires.
Mais je vais pas enfin on va pas se
mentir cette solution en tout cas à
court terme elle est éminemment
compliquée. Premièrement parce que
aujourd'hui vous allez pas proposer un
état au Palestiniens alors que le Hamas
vient de faire ce qu'il a fait.
C'est-à-dire que c'est évidemment une
récompensee au terrorisme et aux
méthodes du du Hamas. Donc c'est
inenvisageable. Et deuxièmement, avant
d'envisager cette solution, il faut être
sûr que bah toutes les ramifications
islamistes soient détruites parce que
sinon vous créez un Daesh euh aux portes
d'Israël. Et évidemment, ça c'est n bien
sûr ni pour Israël mais ni pour les
Européens euh voilà [grognement]
aujourd'hui qui ont des soldats euh
islamistes et djihadistes y compris sur
leur propre sol et qui prennent parfois
leur consignes, on l'a vu, directement à
Gaza ou dans d'autres pays du monde type
Qatar et compagnie. Voilà.
Peut-être [grognement] d'Iran un peu,
non ? et diront oui, même s'il y a pas
eu d'attentat du Esbola en France de
depuis longtemps, mais en tout cas
aujourd'hui en France, c'est plutôt un
terrorisme sunnite.
Quel regard vous portez sur Netaniaahu ?
[soupir]
Bah, je vais vous dire sur le le la
réponse une fois de plus militaire, j'ai
pas les éléments, je vous dis. Je pense
pas qu'il y ait d'intention euh
génocidaire.
Euh voilà, moi je je n'étais pas de
celle qui défendait les politiques de
colonisation sur les territoires
palestinien. Maintenant euh
je c'est compliqué parce que Israël en
même temps euh a eu des phases où euh il
y a eu des tentatives justement euh de
dialogue avec les Palestiniens et puis
c'est précisément d'ailleurs dans les
années où le Hamas a été élu
démocratiquement et et a prospéré. Donc
en fait c'est plein d'occasions
manquées. Euh la réponse est enfin le
Paris d'Israël des départs était un
paris euh incroyable. en même temps euh
beau et incroyable parce que aller
s'installer dans cette partie du monde,
récupérer des terres d'origine pour
reconstruire un état, c'est vrai que
c'est une menace existentielle.
Maintenant, moi j'ai quand même un peu
le réflex spontané de me dire je préfère
quand même qu' aujourd'hui l'existence
bien sûr de cet état qui est un état
quand même euh démocratique, proche des
Européens, qui est aussi un
interlocuteur
naturel dans cette zone du monde parce
que parce que si Israël
disparaît, c'est évidemment un drame
pour les Israéliens, mais c'est aussi un
drame, j'ai envie de dire, pour l'Europe
et ses intérêts géopolitiques dans cette
région. Qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec la
population palestinienne qui est coincée
à la frontière de l'Égypte avec les
bulles d'ozer, les bombardements qui se
rapprochent, qui se rapprochent, qui se
rapprochent ? On fait quoi ?
On n' pas la réponse hein. J'ai envie de
vous dire moi, j'aimerais bien que tous
ces pays arabes du proche Orient qui
sont euh Non, mais ça m'intéresse Bah
oui, non mais d'accord, mais qui sont si
pront à dénoncer l'attitude d'Israël,
voir à à remettre en cause son
existence,
bah accueillir ses réfugiés. Je suis
désolé mais à un moment donné euh les
réfugiés euh politiques euh de guerre
sont pas tous amenés euh à venir euh en
Europe, hein. Il y a aussi pour des
raisons géographiques, culturelles,
spirituelles, des choses qui devraient
être plus évidentes. Le problème, c'est
que les Égyptiens et je je les comprends
aussi, ils ne veulent pas accueillir euh
euh davantage de réfugiés parce qu'ils
veulent pas être déstabilisés de
l'intérieur. [grognement] Euh donc bah
moi je pense toutes les pétromarchies là
qui ont été très véhémantes hein dans
leur dans les qui ont les moyens les
moyens. Donc accue accueillons-les.
Voilà, je trouve que ça serait pour le
coup une solution cohérente avec leur
prise de position.
C'est les accueillir le temps que Israël
remplisse ses objectifs de guerre et
ensuite les remettre là-bas. Ça c'est ça
c'est aux populations de choisir après
où elles ont envie de faire leur vie.
Mais pour palier, on va dire à la crise,
voilà ce que je veux ce que je veux dire
aujourd'hui c'est que une fois de plus,
c'est toujours pareil. On on les ces
pays arabes là ne se posent jamais la
question. Ils sont toujours très
vindicatifs dans leur prise de position.
Il se pose pas la question de savoir
comment ils aident réellement et
concrètement les populations.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait éclirant ?
C'est-à-dire qu'est-ce qu'on fait
avecant ?
On renou des contacts, on les empêche
d'avoir l'arme nucléaire définitivement.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? [soupir]
Bah, je vais pas vous dire que c'est
un bruit de couloir en ce moment chez
les stratèges, c'est Israël va bombarder
l'Iran au nucléaire pour résoudre le
problème définitivement. C'est une vue
de l'esprit.
C'est un fantasme. C'est un truc. Je
je sais pas. La la la la guerre
russoau-rainienne nous démontre que tout
ne tout tout est possible. Après tout,
j'imagine enfin peu de personnes avaient
imaginé queon pouvait avoir comme ça une
invasion
de l'Ukraine aussi violente et et une
guerre si proche. Donc faut faut rien
faut rien exclure. Maintenant, je pense
pas que Israël ouvre ce front
aujourd'hui, ça me paraît compliqué.
Alors qu'ils sont quand même dans une
situation intérieure et politique parce
qu'on parlait de Netaniaahou mais
Netaniaahou aujourd'hui est très
contesté y compris par la population du
fait qu'il n'aurait pas pris au sérieux
les
alertes qui lui avaient été transmises
notamment par l'Égypte je crois
justement sur cette possibilité
d'attaque et le fait qu'il aurait fait
des choix sécuritaires qui étaient
malvenus notamment en abandonnant ces
territoires proches de de Gaza de de la
de surveillance parce qu'il y avait
voilà des menaces plus fortes dans
d'autres parties et et en poussant une
politique de colonisation sans avoir le
moyen d'assurer la la sécurité de ces
populations parce qu'en fait on est à
créer un émettement du territoire avec
des populations et des kibots qui sont
relativement isolés en les exposant
justement à tout cela. Donc aujourd'hui
il
Vous avez déjà été en Israël ?
Non malheureusement j'ai jamais été.
J'aimerais beaucoup.
Il y a de la bonne musique
il paraît et j'aimerais bien y compris
moi pour des raisons spirituelles.
Jérusalem Bethléhem. Vous
crois en Dieu ?
Oui je crois en Dieu.
Comment ça se manifeste ?
Comment ça se manifeste ? Euh comment je
crois en Dieu ? Bah je je c'està-dire
dans ma pratique, vous voulez dire
est-ce que vous avez un ami imaginaire ?
Comment Dieu se manifeste ? Comment vous
percevez ?
Ça c'est une question métaphysique et
trans c'est c'est [rires] pour
déconcentrer.
Oui, c'est ça. Bah, ça marche bien.
[grognement] Euh ça marche bien surtout
que c'est toujours très intime une
relation avec
avec Dieu. Mais non, ça se manifeste
comme une présence invisible mais douce
et rassurante et aimante.
C'est comme ça que vous vous rassurez ?
C'est comme ça que je me rassure aussi.
Ouais. Ça fait partie des choses qui me
donnent de la force.
Combien vous gagnez ?
Bon, je vous dirai pas, ça vous regarde
pas. [rires]
Est-ce que vous faites de l'évasion
fiscale ?
Non. Vous êtes sûr ?
Ah, j'en suis sûr. Je [grognement] vous
dirai pas les yeux dans les yeux parce
qu'il y en a d'autres à qui ça avec qui
ça a mal fini ce genre de déclaration.
C'était Cusac.
C'était cap comment on dit
capillotracté. C'est ça.
Capilo tracté. Ouais. [rires]
L'application des peines.
L'application des peines dans notre
Ah bah mauvais euh
Est-ce que Sarkozy doit aller en prison
?
Mauvais. Ah oui, je pensais que vous
parliez de la justice pénale en général.
La justice pénale, non, il a pas été si
si si si si si. Mais bon, je pense
qu'aujourd'hui le sujet de
on viendra sur la géopolitique juste
après.
Ouais. Ah bah le sujet
on a bien remarqué
le sujet de la difficulté d'application
des peines, elle pour le coup je me
semble dépasse dépasse Nicolas Sarkozy.
Comment on juge une société ? On la juge
comment ? Avec deux facteurs.
Comment on juge une société ?
Ouais.
Je vous donne deux pistes.
Ah oui, les questions et les réponses.
Non
non, c'est pour vous donner à peu près
l'amplitude de mon cadre.
Son respect des animaux et son son
respect des détenus.
[soupir][grognement]
Oui oui, j'aurais pas forcément pris ces
critères là, mais euh bah typiquement
son niveau de sécurité et de civisme, ça
je pense que c'est vraiment une donnée
importante pour mesurer le niveau de
civilisation.
Je pense que c'est ça qui fait que les
sociétés se développent et qu'on puisse
vivre sereinement. Enfin, je dire c'est
bien le rôle d'un état et c'est celui-ci
de c'est celui de garantir cette liberté
là. Aujourd'hui, je considère que le
contrat n'est pas n'est pas rempli par
l'État français de ce point de vue-là.
Euh [grognement]
la sécurité et puis et puis euh
quoi d'autre ? Un deuxième un deuxième
facteur parce que la sécurité découle
beaucoup de choses, mais je c'est ce
dont je vous parlais tout à l'heure en
fait, le fameux sentiment fraternel.
C'est-à-dire que je pense que
je vais élargir un peu le sujet, mais il
y a une chose pour moi qui aujourd'hui
je vous autorise.
Merci. Je vais faire essayer de faire
euh euh [grognement] il y a une chose
pour moi qui menace la démocratie
au-delà du gouvernement des juges euh
c'est justement le multiculturalisme. Je
m'explique, la démocratie c'est pas
uniquement euh un une addition de voix
qui donne un projet parce que pour
dégager un fait majoritaire, il faut
qu'il y ait quand même des fondations
civilisationnelles communes. Faut quand
même que le peuple qui vive sur le
territoire s'accorde globalement
évidemment sur la notion qu'il a du bien
et du mal. du périmètre, des lignes
rouges, des valeurs un peu fondatrices
euh qui font qu'on on peut vivre
ensemble. Le problème, c'est
qu'aujourd'hui avec l'immigration, avec
le multiculturalisme,
on narrive plus vraiment à dégager de
faits majoritaires parce que justement
il y a des visions, des modes de vie qui
se confrontent et qui cohabitent mal. Et
donc, on construit une addition de
minorité. C'est ce que font très souvent
d'ailleurs euh nos gouvernants. Donc on
construit des majorités de circonstances
de façon un peu bancale et qui explosent
euh extrêmement vite au lendemain des
élections, d'où d'ailleurs des
instabilités récurrentes parce qu'on
arrive plus à donner un cap parce que
évidemment les fondations sont trop euh
friables quoi. Et donc ça pour moi c'est
une vraie menace pour la démocratie et
et son bon fonctionnement.
Quelle était ma question ?
Votre question c'était quels sont les
deux facteurs qui font que une société
se porte bien ou en tout cas une
la question c'était comment on juge une
société ?
Ouais. Comment on juge une société ?
Ouais, c'est ça.
Le respect des animaux. Oui. Bah le
[raclement de gorge] respect des animaux
en fait partie mais enfin le respect des
humains déjà
le respect de l'intégrité des humains et
liberté des humains. C'est bien aussi
arrive tout de suite. La devise qui est
en haut du grand manège de l'école de
guerre anciennement collège intermé de
défense
vous savez Hitler adorait les animaux.
Oui non mais si on voulait faire des
points Goldwin.
Non mais je sais pas un point goldin. Je
dis pas que c'est vous.
Gandi aussi hein.
Oui. Oui.
Et le respect, vous parlez de
l'intégrité humaine. Quand on enferme
des gens dans espèce de cloa qui
prennent l'humidité où ils sont à 15 par
terre qui
Ah mais moi je suis d'accord avec vous.
Je pense qu'il faut construire des
prisons. Je crois pas qu'il faille vider
les prisons parce que je trouve qu'au
contraire parfois elles sont pas assez
remplies et que ça dure pas assez
longtemps. Je pense qu'il faut
construire.
Le taux d'occupation en France des
prisons. C'est combien ?
Mais oui mais d'accord c'est
on a été condamné combien de fois par
oui non mais ça je suis d'accord avec
vous. Bien, on est dans un état
surpopulation carcérale. Je dis pas
qu'on doit s'en féliciter, mais je pense
que la réponse, elle est pas de vider
les prisons. Elle est pas la
démonstration que la politique pénale en
réalité est plus dure. Elle est
simplement la démonstration que la
criminalité dans le pays augmente et que
les le parc carcéral n'est plus adapté
aujourd'hui au taux de criminalité dans
le pays.
C'est le parc carcéral où c'est la
pédagogie apportée à la la quand quand
les gens purgent leur peine ?
Non, c'est le parc carcéral. C'està dire
qu'on a plus assez de place par rapport
aujourd'hui au niveau de délinquence qui
est celui de la France et donc on a des
états de surpopulation carcérale. Et de
ce point de vue-là, je parle une fois de
plus, moi je fais partie des gens qui
déjà quand j'avais été élu en 2012
plaidait pour qu'on ait à minima 15000
places de prison supplémentaire et le
compte n'y est toujours pas parce que je
crois que le gouvernement on a fait
construire à peine 2500 ou 2800 depuis
qu'il est aux affaires. Donc oui
d'accord ça coûte cher mais à un moment
donné il faut choisir ses priorités.
Comment vous expliquez que les pays
nordiques euh convertissent leur prison
en hôtel de luxe ?
Bah peut-être déjà parce qu'ils ont pas
euh nécessairement les taux
d'immigration qui sont les nôtres. j'y
reviens hein, mais que du coup les taux
de criminalité ne sont pas
nécessairement les mêmes. Et d'ailleurs,
c'est de moins en moins vrai hein parce
que si aujourd'hui euh on voit des
gouvernements de droite arriver aux
affaires qui sont très dures sur
l'immigration, pas forcément que de
droite d'ailleurs, je pense notamment au
Danemark qui était plutôt gouvernement
issu de la gauche, c'est parce que
justement ils ont vécu de manière plus
intense et très en étant très court
notamment après la crise de la Syrie,
des flux d'immigration très importants,
en particulier en Suède et ils ont vu
d'un coup les conséquences sur la
criminalité. Euh et donc on va dire le
fameux modèle nordique de bien vivre
ensemble a explosé. Et ce qui est très
intéressant, je vous invite à une une
étude fond d'Apôle euh Dominique Rignier
sur ce sujet qui a étudié les raisons
pour laquelles les Danois notamment
avaient euh il y avait un consensus
droite gauche au Danemark sur la
régulation de l'immigration et la
première raison c'est pour sauver leur
modèle social. Vous savez dans les pays
du nord ils ont des modèles sociaux
protection sociale très forte. Ils sont
très attachés. Ça fait vraiment partie
de leur un peu comme en France
d'ailleurs he de l'identité du pays
quoi. Et bah eux ils ont compris que
l'ouverture des frontières ça marchait
pas avec la défense d'un modèle de leur
modèle social et donc il fallait
choisir. Voilà. Et donc ils ont choisi.
On a le réchauffement climatique qui
commence à mettre des zones dans le
monde inhabitable. On a des précarités
économiques, des gens qui sont connectés
à internet et qui voient l'Eldorado en
Europe. On voit des gens mourir dans la
Méditerranée, un immense cimetière dans
la Méditerranée.
C'est pas des facteurs qui vont
s'arrêter, c'est des facteurs qui vont
continuer qui vont continuer. Qu'est-ce
qu'on fait nous, l'Europe ?
On construit un mur, on fait un blocus
maritime, on aide le développement sur
place, on évite que les gens clament en
pleine Méditerranée avec des br avant
clam c'est des brûlures de mazout dans
les zodiaques, la traite des hommes, le
marché aux esclaves en Libye et j'en
passé des meilleurs de l'esclavagisme,
des viols, des coups et de j'en passe.
On fait quoi ?
Alors, il y a plein de choses dans votre
question. Première chose, vous savez, il
y a euh d'après les Nations- Unies, il y
a à peu près un/4 euh de la population
mondiale qui su qui se qui vit dans des
zones en situation de conflit. Donc si
le principe c'est de dire que la France
a vocation à accepté toutes les
personnes qui subissent des zones de
conflit, je peux vous dire qu'on n pas
fini parce que un quart de la population
mondiale, ça va faire beaucoup. Donc
moi, je considère, je remets en cause ce
principe qui explique qu'aujourd'hui la
France a un devoir,
comment dire d'accueil et d'hospitalité
inconstitutionnel et illimité. Alors,
une fois de plus, je vous le dirais, on
serait euh euh on serait richissime dans
une situation de prospérité, à ne plus
savoir quoi faire de de notre argent, de
nos places d'hébergement, de J'ai envie
de vous dire très bien, soyons
fraternels, mais on n'est objectivement
plus dans cette situation et et là
aujourd'hui, c'est la le la survie même
de la France en tant que civilisation
française et européenne qui qui est
menacé. Alors, moi, je considère qu'on
doit quand même avoir le droit de
pouvoir continuer de d'exister en tant
que peuple, en tant que civilisation et
en tant que nation. Euh [grognement]
donc ça c'est la première chose. La
deuxième chose c'est quand vous regardez
les les je parle de l'immigration légale
pour le coup les premiers titres de
séjour les nationalités qui sont les
premières bénéficiaires des premiers
titres de séjour on a Algérie, Maroc,
Tunisie. Alors je vous dis pas que ces
pays sont dans des situations
économiques merveilleuses et
incroyables. Mais c'est
Algérie, ça va pas mal non ?
Oui. Non bien sûr. Pour ça que je vous
dis que tout est pas parfait et il y a
des parfois des dérives
semi-autoritaires et tout. Ce que je
peux vous dire, c'est qu'en tout cas, on
peut pas dire que ce soit les pays les
plus affamés ou face à des crises
climatiques majeures. Donc,
vous avez été en Algérie ou Maroc ?
Oui, j'ai été au Maroc et en Tunisie,
pas en Algérie. Ça où ça ?
J'ai été à chaque fois dans les
capitales et puis une fois,
non, pas que au club. [grognement]
Mais vous avez été comment ? Sac à dos
ou
Oui ? Oui, c'était des voyages
personnels à chaque fois. Je suis pas
allée dans le cadre politique.
Mais dans quel cadre ? Parce qu'il y a
voyage personnel et voyages personnel
c'estàd que
oui enfin je veux bien vous raconter je
veux bien vous raconter ma vie. Non non,
c'était c'était pour le coup voilà
visite découverte du pays. C'était pas
au climat [grognement] euh
un tour opérator ou vous avez pas un
tour opérator non plus. Mais mais bon,
au-delà de ça, tout ça pour vous dire
que au-delà de de ma vie passionnante,
ce c'est immigration, pardon.
Vous avez appris quel mot là-bas ?
Des gros mots comme à chaque fois qu'on
va à l'étranger en premier mot. Mais je
vais pas vous le dire. Vous m'avez dit
pas de gros mots, pas de diffamation.
[rires] Donc et non, ce que je veux vous
dire, c'est que là typiquement on est
face à une immigration,
pas de dénigrement. et pas de
dénigrement, pas une immigration euh
climatique ou euh ou de lié à des
conflits, on est une migration
économique. Voilà, ça c'est factuel. Et
deuxième chose, là pour le coup, je vais
vous prendre les demandeurs d'asile euh
qui rentrent bien souvent
clandestinement sur le territoire pour
demander l'asile, d'où le fait que ce
soit devenu une fier d'immigration.
Première nationalité qui demande, je
vous épargne les suivantes,
c'est l'Afghanistan. Donc l'Afghanistan,
il y a
les sources
alors les sources à chaque fois c'est le
ministère de l'intérieur. Sur
l'immigration de manière générale, je
vais vous faire gagner du temps. C'est
moi j'utilise que des sources
officielles. Ministère de l'intérieur
euh INC cours des comptes et quand c'est
des trucs européens parfois l'OCDE
euh comme ça au moins je suis pas
embêté.
Et donc l'Afghanistan alors évidemment
je dis pas que la vie des populations en
Afghanistan est merveilleuse, loin sans
faut, loin sans faut, mais vous savez,
il y a à peu près
près 6000 km, plus de 6000 km entre nous
et l'Afghanistan. Est-ce que
objectivement euh c'est le devoir de la
France en premier lieu de devoir
accueillir les réfugiés d'Afghanistan ?
Une fois plus, j'en suis pas absolument
convaincu et je considère que la France
a largement fait son devoir. Donc il
s'agit pas d'être dans on construit des
murs, on en a rien à faire. Il s'agit de
dire qu'aujourd'hui notre premier devoir
de responsable politique, c'est d'abord
d'assurer la survie, la prospérité,
l'intégrité et la sécurité du pays. Et
que donc ça, bah c'est pas compatible
avec une immigration euh de masse,
qu'elle soit légale ou illégale venu de
pays dont le moteur principal est
d'abord un un sujet économique.
C'est combien de masses déjà ? Bah alors
aujourd'hui, on est en premier titre de
séjour à peu près euh alors en 2023,
c'était autour de 320000 quelque chose
comme ça. Il y a à peu près 2 millions
d'entrées légal sous euh sous Emmanuel
Macron depuis qu'il était arrivé, hein.
Donc c'est considéré. Sûr de vos
chiffres ?
Ah, j'en suis sûr.
C'est peut-être 327000. Mais enfin, en
tout cas, c'est je suis absolument sûr
des ordres de grandeur. On est donc ça
c'est un record cette année mais record
d'ailleurs depuis Emmanuel Macron est
aux affaires. On a des records
d'immigration. C'est peut-être parce que
les talibans ont commencé à se
manifester d'une façon beaucoup plus
revenir. Mais moi je pense que le
premier sujet c'est la démographie. En
fait, on est face à un déséquilibre
démographique avec une explosion des
populations en Afrique et en Europe qui
fait que mécaniquement voilà et puis
puis les modèles attractifs français
pour plein de raisons économiques,
sociales. Voilà.
Euh, on est à peu près record aussi
d'immigration clandestine aux frontières
européennes, chiffre de Frontex, à peu
près 300000 entrées cette année. Record
de demandeur d'asile cette année encore,
mais c'est un record quasi continu
depuis des années, plus de 100000.
Record de mineurs isolés. En fait,
aujourd'hui, c'est la perte de contrôle
partout, voilà, tout le temps, partout
et dans tous les domaines. Euh donc
c'est pour le coup, c'est factuel.
Voilà, c'est factuel et donc bah tout ça
participe oui, d'un changement de
population dans certains territoires
avec toute l'évolution que toute
l'évolution s'incomporte. Donc pour vous
répondre sur le réchauffement
climatique, on parlera peut-être
d'écologie après et de ce qu'il faut
faire.
Il me reste une demi-heure donc est-ce
qu'on gratte un peu plus ? Non parce que
j'ai
un sandwich au jambon si vous voulez
déjà je vais [rires] boire si vous
permettez. H
donc déjà la question c'est
réchauffement climatique. Oui.
Voulez un bout de fromage ?
Euh non ça va merci. J'ai trop peur
d'avoir un truc dans les dents après.
[rires]
Euh
donc la souffrance des gens qui
traversent les frontières.
Déjà la question c'est la question de
l'adaptation. Bon, c'est marrant parce
que on se on se pose toujours la
question de savoir comment on peut
endiguer, ralentir, empêcher le
réchauffement climatique. Je vais pas
vous mentir, je suis pas très optimiste.
Surtout euh si on considère que euh
la part de la responsabilité humaine est
euh majoritaire, si ce n'est
déterminante ou décisive,
et occidental,
bah aujourd'hui. Aujourd'hui, la France
c'est 1 % des émissions de CO2 et
l'Europe, c'est 9 %. Donc on peut pas
dire ça.
Notre pollution exportée, elle est ou
importée, elle est elle est
bah elle est plutôt importée d'ailleurs.
D'où le vrai sujet puisqueaujourd'hui
c'est le paradoxe d'ailleurs euh en fait
on on produit moins de gaz à effet de
serre mais pourtant autant l'empreinte
carbone reste très importante parce
qu'en fait la ça c'est les chiffres du
ministère de l'environnement la moitié
des émissions de CO2 en fait aujourd'hui
sont liées aux importations. D'où bah
toujours pareil he une vraie une vraie
politique écologique cohérente, c'est
d'abord une politique qui produit locale
au maximum et aujourd'hui c'est pas les
modèles
et donc les migrants, on en fait quoi
dans tout ça ? Et donc les migrants, bah
comme je vous le disais aujourd'hui, on
ne on ne peut plus assurer euh leur euh
leur euh leur accueil, ça c'est une
certitude. Euh donc il faut les
dissuader de venir, hein, donc par des
politiques euh dissuasives qui soient à
la fois par le droit euh mais qui soit
aussi par la fin des incitations à cette
immigration dont je vous le rappelle, je
vous le redis à l'instant, qui est
majoritairement d'ailleurs de moteur
économique.
Est-ce qu'on peut arrêter quelqu'un qui
a faim ? Oui, mais là en l'occurrence,
c'est pas arrêter quelqu'un qui a peur
comme je vous le disais, c'est pas le
c'est pas le c'est pas la fin dans la
plupart des nationalités qui poussent.
Euh, excusez-moi, mais le le l'algérien,
le marocain ou le tunisien qui vient, il
vient pas parce qu'il a faim. il vient
parce que il sait qu'en France bah s'il
arrive, il sera euh logé euh en HLM,
qu'il aura le droit mécaniquement, même
sans avoir jamais cotisé de sa vie euh à
des à des aides diverses et variées, les
APL, les allocations familiales, voire
même une retraite hein, parce qu'à
partir de 65 ans, vous avez l'aspa qui
fait que même quand vous avez jamais
bossé en France, vous avez un minimum
plus intéressant quand vous êtes
combien ?
C'est autour de, je vais pas dire de
bêtises, un peu plus de 700, entre 700
et 800. Voilà. Euh donc pas mal quand
même hein, c'est le moment qu'on puisse
dire euh que vous allez même peut-être
pouvoir envoyer une partie de cet argent
euh au bled et que bah pour toutes ces
raisons au bled et donc pour tout
cprisant dans ma bouche hein. Euh et
donc pour toutes ces raisons bah de fait
c'est plus intéressant de venir en
France. Voilà mais tout ça le problème
c'est que se fait sur le coup de
l'endettement français. Et
où est-ce que vous avez voyagé dans
votre vie ? Quel pays vous avez fait ?
Vous voulez que je vous raconte ma vie
quoi. En fait j'étais parti pour vous
parler d'écologie. Mais on va y venir.
Bah
je sais pas si c'est très intéressant
mais bah j'ai voyagé. Quoi de pays ?
Combien de semaines vous êtes restés ?
Quel est le pays pour vous le plus
pourri que vous ayez visité en terme
économique ? En terme de plus pourri,
en terme d'infrastructure,
en terme de maladie, en terme de
Je vais pas me faire des amis. Mais
l'Inde c'était compliqué ?
Ah bah l'Inde c'est compliqué pour les
occidentaux hein. Vous avez eu un petit
peu une tourista aggravé il y a un début
de choléra. Ah
oui, il faut qu'on rentre dans ce niveau
de
de papier to
Tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
je suis rentré en ayant moins de poids
qu'en arrivant. tout le monde en [rires]
général.
Voilà, c'est ça mais euh est-ce que vous
avez vu de vous ? J'ai fait bah j'ai
fait la capitale et j'ai fait le
Rajastan.
Le Rajastan avec tous les beaux
monuments.
Avec tous les beaux monuments.
Exactement.
Quelle est la chose la plus difficile
que vous ayez pu voir en Inde ?
Ah bah en Inde, c'est la misère. La
misère des enfants. Bah ça c'est ça par
contre c'est prenant bien sûr. Les
enfants qui voilà vous sollicitent
beaucoup y compris.
Comment on les appelle ?
Comment on les appelle ? intouchable.
Euh oui oui pour ceux qui en effet font
partie des castes parce qu'en fait ce
système de cast qui existe toujours dans
les faits même s'il a été interdit par
la loi indienne. Mais comme quoi
vous avez appris quelques mots là-bas ?
Comment on dit bonjour ? Comment ça va ?
Ah non non j'ai pas non franchement non.
Je suis désolé là pour le coup je vais
vous décevoir. Je ne parle ni indien ni
latin. Je suis en dessous de tout.
[rires]
Oui je sais
au Pakistan Ourou.
Très bien. Écoutez
quel autre pays et combien de temps vous
êtes resté là-bas ?
C'est vraiment intéressant ou quoi ?
Parce qu'en plus ça date, je sais pas,
je suis j'ai dû rester 10 jours. Voilà.
Quel autre pays vous avez fait ?
Alors, j'ai fait les pays genre j'ai
voyagé pas mal en Europe euh déjà parce
que c'est déjà pas mal de connaître un
peu l'Europe. J'ai fait l'Italie,
l'Espagne, la Suisse,
l'Allemagne, l'Autriche.
[grognement] Euh qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
d'autre ? J'ai fait la Suède,
j'ai fait la Finlande, je suis allée en
Russie où
ça
j'ai fait j'ai fait que Moscou. Non,
j'ai fait Saint-Pétersbourg aussi. J'ai
fait donc bah pays du Maghreb, je vous
en ai parlé tout à l'heure. Euh
l'Amérique du Sud un peu,
non ? L'Amérique du Sud, j'ai eu des
occasions euh Afrique Côte d'Ivoire
et voilà. Non, peu de temps. C'était un
voyage perso aussi.
Voilà. Bon, je vois bref c'est
c'est pas captivant. Je parle anglais,
italien
écologie après avoir voyagé. [rires]
Oui, vraiment
la compensation carbone de tout ça
en fait faut quand même une agilité euh
parce que là j'étais reparti dans mes
vacances moi. Ça y est [rires]
dans mes déplacements. Euh l'écologie
alors
je je voulais vous en parler juste avant
que vous me demandiez de me raconter de
raconter ma tourista en Inde. J'ai
[rires]
l'écologie. Alors moi je première chose
au bout de combien de jours ? [rires]
Première chose ça suffit. Première
chose, l'écologie. Alors, le
réchauffement climatique, euh est-ce
qu'on arrivera nous européens, nous
Français à l'endiguer, le ralentir à
nous tout seul ? J'y crois pas.
Quand l'Europe nous demande la nous la
France d'utiliser 44 % de nuclé de de
pardon 44 % d'énergie renouvelable,
je vais bah justement je vais y venir.
Mais pourquoi je vous dis ça ? parce que
je commence par la fin et après je vais
vous parler de des du chemin. Je
considère que parce que aujourd'hui
l'Europe a pas les moyens à elle toute
seule et la France encore moins de
pouvoir bah baisser massivement les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
mondiaux et donc de pouvoir jouer
là-dessus. La question qu'on devrait se
poser et qu'on se pose jamais, c'est
comment on adapte notre économie au
réchauffement climatique. Et c'est
d'ailleurs aussi la question qu'on
devrait se poser, y compris dans l'aide
au développement des pays qui vont être
les premières victimes de ça et
notamment sur le plan agricole parce
qu'il va y avoir évidemment des des
types de production qui vont devoir
évoluer selon les territoires avec bon
bah cette trajectoire même si
aujourd'hui évidemment on n' pas une
idée très très claire de comment ce
réchauffement peut arriver dans quelle
proportion enfin c'est que tout ça est
extrêmement flou mais en tout cas il y a
un réchauffement donc adaptation et ça
l'adaptation dans la transition on n
parle jamais on a on a pas du tout de
vision claire là-dessus pas du tout
d'investissement en ce sens donc ça pour
Pour moi, c'est une première chose. La
deuxième chose, je m'inscris pas du tout
dans la logique actuelle et ce que
j'appelle pour moi un fanatisme
écologique qui est notamment révélé par
le fameux Pact Vert qui était le grand
projet écologique d'Ursula Vlon, donc
qui était la l'objectif de réduction à
55 % des gaz à effet de serre euh des
émotions de CO2 en particulier d'ici
2030. Et je trouvais que j'ai lu un
rapport qui est celui qui m'a le plus
convaincu sur le sujet, un rapport de
l'Institut Saint-Pience qui est donc un
sing tank libéral intéressant sur le
sujet et qui pour moi résume bien le
problème parce qu'il disait que c'était
les fameux il disait qu'il 4 I donc déjà
euh enfin inaccessible en terme
d'objectif. Ça veut dire queon peut pas
tenir ces objectifs sauf d'être dans une
logique de décroissance donc
d'approvisement
d'appauvrissement pardon. Euh je
m'étends pas sur le détail mais injuste
parce qu'en plus on oublie de dire une
chose, c'est que ces objectifs de
réduction, ils se font par rapport à ce
que émettait chaque pays européen dans
les années 90. Or, en France euh on
émettait dans les années 90 deux fois
moins de CO2 que l'Allemagne et pourtant
on a les mêmes objectifs de réduction
avec une population qui va augmenter
d'ici là de près de 11 millions
d'habitants. Mais c'est du délire,
c'està dire que c'est complètement
injuste. Euh euh donc c'est insoutenable
sur le plan économique. Il y a un
rapport qui a été fait commandé
d'ailleurs par le gouvernement de France
stratégie
Pisaniféri de mémoire qui
estime à peu près 66 milliards par an le
coût de cette transition écologique.
Donc avec potentiellement, c'est eux qui
le disent, un endettement supplémentaire
de 25 % donc c'est économiquement
insoutenable et surtout c'est inutile.
C'està dire que ce qu'on disait à
l'instant, la France 1 % des émissions
dans le monde et l'Europe c'est 9 % donc
en plus ça ça ne va pas endiguer la
chose. Et le pire c'est que dans ce
rapport de France stratégie ils le
disent eux-même. Il dit "Oui, c'est vrai
que c'est inutile mais en fait c'est une
c'est une c'est une injonction morale à
laquelle on doit se plier." Donc en fait
on fait tout ça. Donc on est en train de
vouloir détruire notre agriculture,
détruire notre industrie, organiser la
décroissance, donc l'appauvérissement du
pays pour un truc dont en plus tout le
monde s'accorde à dire que ce sera
inutile. Donc moi, je m'inscris pas du
tout là-dedans. Maintenant, comment je
le décline ? On va dire, une fois que
j'ai dit ça, je dire OK, bon bah c'est
ce pacte est délirant. Comment je le
décline dans ma vision énergétique ?
Parce que évidemment l'écologie c'est
d'abord aussi une politique énergétique.
Bah là, je suis pas du tout en accord
avec le projet du gouvernement. C'est
dire que le gouvernement, bon, pendant
longtemps, il a dit, on va pas y
revenir, on a suffisamment parlé, il a
dit le nucléaire. D'ailleurs, ça c'était
les les lobby allemands et les services
de renseignement allemand qui ont œuvré
de manière significative auprès de la
source.
Oh bah l'école de guerre économique le
G.
Exactement. L'école de guerre économique
a fait un rapport sur le sujet
extrêmement intéressant. Passe le
bonjour à monsieur
Monsieur Arbulot exactement qui fait un
travail très intéressant
et qui pour le coup a révélé que le
nucléaire français était un tel avantage
compétitif pour la France par rapport à
l'industrie allemand que les Allemands
ont organisé évidemment le le sabotage
et les élites françaises se sont fait
avoir et ont plongé dedans à fond. C'est
extraordinaire. Donc on a perdu 20 ans
sur le nucléaire. Donc on est
Ils ont plongé ou est-ce que c'était une
forfaiture ?
Ah bah moi je considère que c'est de la
forfaiture. Ouais parce que un moment
donné ça dire quoi forfaiture ?
Bah la forfaiture c'est de la trahison
en fait. C'est c'est de la trahison.
Sauf que à un moment donné on peut se
dire tout à l'heure ce qu'on a dit. On
peut dire c'est de la compétence et de
la naïveté mais enfin on peut aussi
trahir par connerie hein. Donc donc de
fait le résultat est le même. Non mais
pardon mais c'est la réalité aujourd'hui
c'est que quoi ? que on a saboté cette
filière, on va mettre des années à
rattraper si on y arrive avec des
investissements considérables tout le
temps qu'on a perdu. On a plus en plus
la main d'homme nécessaire. Donc, il va
falloir rattraper en catastrophe
le savoir-faire
et ce savoir-faire. Exactement. Et donc,
on a un gouvernement qui en parallèle
donc de ces fameuses promesses de 14 PR,
bon, on a déjà perdu 2 ans mais voilà,
même si moi je valide sur le principe
hein, nous dit bah
c'est pas un peu du blabla.
Bah, j'espère pas. Quand Agnès Panirué
nous dit "On a besoin de 100000
recrutements de
C'est très ambitieux en tout cas. C'est
très ambitieux et pour l'instant il
s'est rien passé encore. Donc
disz les étoiles au moins vous arriverez
sur la Lune". C'est ça.
Bah c'est toujours mieux en tout cas
déjà de de se donner des objectifs parce
que évidemment c'est incontournable.
Maintenant
c'est pas un peu du Yakaca Faucon ?
Bah non c'est pas du Yaka Faucon parce
que on est on est capable aujourd'hui de
construire des EPR. On peut si on s'en
donne les moyens, mais pour ça, il faut
il faut une po
Comment vous interprétez la la volte
face de d'Emmanuel Macron qui a qui a eu
fermé des réacteurs ?
Il s'est réveillé, il a compris, il
s'est fait informer, il a décidé
d'arrêter de faire de la subordnation de
vote par opportunisme politique. Non,
c'est de l'électoralisme l'Ukraine.
C'est ça.
Bah en fait, c'est comme sur la
souveraineté industrielle, la
souveraineté des médicaments, c'est le
Covid en fait. C'est électoral. à chaque
fois ils font n'importe quoi jusqu'à ce
que ça se paye parce que bah à un moment
donné il y a une tension sur les
marchés, il y a une rupture
d'approvisionnement euh et puis bah donc
ça se transmort en pénurie ou en manque
et donc pendant le bah pendant le le
dernier conflit russoau-rainien, on a dû
importer de l'électricité, ce qui quand
même nous était pas arrivé depuis un
sacré moment parce que bah on avait plus
assez de production nationale et qu'en
plus la plupart de nos EPR étaient en
on a remis aussi des centrales à charbon
et on a remis des centrales à charbon et
donc bah pour palier à ça le
gouvernement dit bon Bah c'est génial,
on va supra méga investir sur le modèle
allemand qui marche pas d'ailleurs dans
les éoliennes. Euh et donc l'objectif du
gouvernement d'ici 2050, c'est de
construire l'équivalent pour les
éoliennes offshore de 90er. Donc je sais
pas si vous voyez le parc. Donc autant
vous dire que c'est parfaitement
délirant et inaccessible tout ça pour
pouvoir tenir leurs objectifs de
production. Donc c'est du pipo complet.
Donc moi je vais pour faire très simple
hein, je dire moi je je pense pas que la
solution elle soit majoritairement ou de
façon substantielle dans les éoliennes
et le solaires. Je pense que le modèle
idéal que j'aurais aimé défendre depuis
des années si on avait investi et qu'on
était encore bon, c'était en fait le
couple hydroélectricité et nucléaire. Ça
c'était le modèle parfait pour la
France. Bon, de fait aujourd'hui on a
pris du retard et puis la la demande va
doubler d'ici 2050, donc il va falloir
s'équiper. Je pense que c'est un
mensonge que de dire qu'on va se passer
du gaz. Voilà, je suis pas une experte
mais quand je regarde un peu tous les
gens sérieux sur le sujet en fait ça
c'est de l'idéologie pure. Donc la
question c'est de dire qu'il faut garder
du gaz dans le mix si on veut tenir nos
objectifs de production et répondre à la
demande qui va augmenter. Mais pour ça,
il faut autonomie, c'est pas possible
mais sécuriser les approvisionnements.
Donc diversifier les sources
d'approvisionnement.
Je pense que sur le nucléaire, il faut
aussi se poser la question du de
l'allongé de la durée de vie des des
évidemment des EPR cu.
Exactement. Aux États-Unis, ils sont en
train de passer de 60 à 80 ans. Donc je
pense qu'il faut pas s'interdire de
faire des études sur le sujet. Ça
règlerait une grande partie de notre
problème. Il y a aussi ce projet des des
petits réacteurs nucléaires, les fameux
SMR. [grognement]
Moi je trouve pas ça je trouve pas ça
pipo. Je trouve qu'il y a des choses
vraiment prometteuses et intéressantes.
En plus c'est un savoir-faire français
européen sur lequel on est on est plutôt
bon en terme d'étude. On
va pas été encore acheté par les
Américains. Non
non pas encore. Donc voilà mais je
trouve que c'est un c'est un modèle de
développement pour des zones
industrielles par exemple. Ça crée de la
chaleur en plus. Donc pour toute une
partie de l'industrie, ce serait
vraiment une solution intéressante. Euh
et puis et puis sur sur tout ce qui est
éolien solaire, oui, ça on peut pas
s'appuyer majoritairement là-dessus. Ça
veut dire qu'il faut que ce soit une
partie de la production mais peut-être
davantage pour faire de l'hydrogène sur
des sur des choses précises et non pas
comme la majeure partie de notre
production.
Oui, il me reste 15 minutes. C'est
chronique chez Reconquête de faire des
petits entretiens.
Des petits entretiens d' 1h45 [rires]
Non, je sais pas. C'est parce queà, on
tient pas la distance, on fatigue vite.
Qu'est-ce que voulez que je vous dise ?
La prochaine fois, il faudra m'accro des
3h parce queil nous reste plein de trucs
à aborder.
Oui. Oui. Ben en plus je dans j'essaie
de parler vite pour dire plein de choses
mais euh ça suffit pas manifestement.
Na euh qui est mort.
[grognement]
Ouais. Suspect. Bah je veux pas vous
dire le contraire hein. Voilà. Après euh
là pour le coup que l'opposition
politique soit de plus en plus muselée
peut-être plus que jamais en Russie
depuis des décennies, c'est paraît une
évidence.
Assange en QHS,
quartier de haute sécurité.
Bah, je veux pas vous dire que ça me je
que ça me réjouit puisqueen
l'occurrence, je trouve qu'il a plutôt
servi l'information mondiale. Mais
voilà, les Américains évidemment
défendent leurs intérêts dans cette
histoire. Donc il pe pas laisser ce
genre de profil libre complètement
donner donner envie à d'autres.
Exactement.
Je suis très frustré de pouvoir pas
avoir de longues réponses. Donc on parle
de quoi là ?
Ben j'ai je l'impression d'avoir fait
plutôt des réponses longues depuis le
début mais
non. [grognement] Ah voilà. Donc vous
m'engueulez parce qu'il reste un quart
d'heure et vous avez plus de question à
me poser.
Si si j'en ai plein d'autres [rires]
mais mais
fa parler de mes vacances.
Guerre économique,
on peut parler de votre tourista si vous
voulez.
Ouais c'est ça.
Guerre économique, on fait quoi ? On il
y a
bah guerre économique guerre. Alors déjà
un moi je je suis sensible au sujet, je
suis pas du tout une experte, je vous le
dis franchement mais je suis sensible au
sujet.
Que je suis pas une experte. Bah parce
que les journées faut 24 heures et que
quand on est un politique, faut toucher
à plein de choses. Donc on se spécialise
plus ou moins dans certains domaines,
mais on peut pas être expert en tout.
C'est un mensonge. Politiques qui vous
disent "Je sais tout sur tout" et qui
répondent à tout. Honnêtement euh
C'est qui votre meilleur conseiller en
guerre économique ?
Ah moi je suis pas mal de les travaux
justement de de Christian Arbuot.
[grognement]
dans l'école que j'ai fondé LICEP, on a
d'ailleurs intégré de de l'intelligence
économique parce que comme on a on
espère en a vocation à former des des
élites politiques, on considère qu'elles
doit avoir la conscience de ce domaine.
Et c'est vrai que là-dessus, on a un
certain retard en France, hein, même si
les choses bougent bougent
laborieusement depuis quelques années.
Bah guerre économique. Et bah tout ça
pour vous dire que même si les lois
quelques lois ces dernières années sont
allé plutôt dans le bon sens, on est
encore loin du compte he parce que quand
on voit qu'aujourd'hui les données de
santé vont être hébergées chez
Microsoft, que EDF vient de passer par
cloud cloud [grognement] d'Amazon et non
pas des des clouds des solutions de
cloud nationaux pour pour une fois plus
héberger des données, on se rend compte
que bah les lois ne suffisent pas, la
contrainte n'est pas là, le cadre
européen n'est pas assez donc plus proté
Enfin bon donc
non malheureusement
le compte n'y est pas.
Vous utilisez de l'intelligence
artificielle tous les jours ou pas ?
Ah bah de toute façon maintenant
l'intelligence artificielle il en il y
en a partout.
Vous utilisez un une un assistant ?
Un assistant ?
Nous on appelle ça un assistant.
Un chat GPT ou
Ouais, je je vais de temps en temps sur
chat GPT. Je trouve ça c'est assez
fascinant. Voilà, maintenant il y a
beaucoup de bêtises encore de dessus
donc faut quand même bien recouper. Mais
moi je trouve ça moi je trouve ça plutôt
enthousiasmant en fait. Ça ne me fait
pas peur euh ça ne me fait pas peur si
tentait que une fois de plus la France
et l'Europe rate pas complètement ce ce
tournant là quoi.
Est-ce [grognement] que la France et
l'Europe financent le la production
d'intelligence artificielle américaine ?
Ça je ne sais pas. Ça je sais pas.
Ce qui est sûr en tout cas, c'est que de
manière générale, on le voit d'ailleurs
dans les fameux marchés dont on vient de
parler ou de ces entreprises là, rien
n'est fait pour favoriser le
développement de nos propres solutions.
Ça c'est une c'est une évidence, mais
c'est vrai d'ailleurs dans ce domaine
là, mais c'est vrai aussi dans le monde
industriel, dans le domaine écologique.
Ça veut dire que chaque fois qu'on se
donne les moyens d'avoir des
investissements privés, notamment sur la
transition écologique, on le fait pour
financer des importations chinoises ou
du sud-est asiatique de de des panneaux
solaires et et de l'éolien. Donc au
moins les Américains ont cette logique
là dans la mesure de du possible.
Typiquement quand ils font par exemple
des bonus écologiques sur les voitures
électriques, voilà bah ils le font pour
les voitures américaines. Et ça c'est
vrai que c'est exactement ça c'est vrai
que c'est une grosse grosse carence de
de l'Union européenne.
Question internet, les prisons sont
remplies d'étrangers ou alors de pauvres
?
Bah elles sont en tout cas il y a 25 %
de détenus qui sont de nationalité
étrangère. Voilà, c'est ce que c'est ce
que j'ai voulu dire. Maintenant, de
pauvre,
non, je crois pas que les trafiquants de
drogue soient très pauvres. [grognement]
Est-ce que vous pensez que les
guetteteurs, les chouffeurs sont pauvres
?
Je crois pas aujourd'hui que la France
soit un pays qui organise ou qui laisse
prospérer la misère de ces populations.
Je pense que le gueteur, il est pas
guetteur parce que il a faim ou qu'il a
pas de logement. Euh objectivement, il
faut arrêter avec le ce misérabilisme,
c'est pas vrai. Euh il est gueteur parce
que par que c'est plus sympa de gagner
euh facilement euh 3000 à 5000 balles
par mois euh que d'aller à l'école ou de
se lever le matin pour aller bosser, de
payer des impôts. Moi, je crois que
c'est surtout ça la raison.
Est-ce que vous souhaitez le retour du
bagne ? du bagne [grognement] euh
c'est-à-dire le bagne fermé haute
sécurité euh sur nos territoires
d'outrevers. C'est ça. [grognement]
Écoutez, je sais pas si ce serait plus
efficace qu'une préson haute sécurité
euh classique. En tout cas, ce qui est
sûr aujourd'hui, c'est qu'on a un vrai
problème avec le les détenus
radicalisés, voir les terroristes
islamistes. C'est-à-dire [grognement]
que aujourd'hui ce qui est une exception
à savoir l'isolement et qui est censé
être une punition est utilisée de
manière détournée pour éviter éviter la
profil les plus risqués d'être au
contact avec les autres. Mais on voit
bien qu'on a des quartiers qui sont pas
adaptés matériellement et sur le plan
organisationnel pour éviter que ces
profils justement fassent du
prosélitisme dans les dans les prisons
et ça c'est un vrai sujet.
Question internet : faut-il ficher tout
le monde pour garantir la sécurité ?
Euh non, je n'espère pas [rires] mais en
tout cas il faut euh euh il faut faire
en sorte que ceux qui soient fichés euh
ne soit pas ne reste pas des bombes à
retardement. C'est-à-dire que moi, je
considère que quand aujourd'hui on a des
étrangers euh qui sont fichés s pour
islamisme euh dans ce pays et qu'on
laisse en totale liberté alors qu'on
sait qu'ils ont non pas des actes mais
en tout cas des comportements suspects
qui peuvent les rendre potentiellement
dangereux, je comprends pas qu'il reste
aujourd'hui sur le territoire français.
L'intelligence artificielle, la
reconnaissance faciale qui est en train
de se déployer pour les Jeux Olympiques.
Vous en pensez quoi ? C'est bien, c'est
pas bien, c'est Big Brother, c'est pas
Big Brower, ça va disparaître après les
Jeux Olympiques, on va le garder comme
par magie et c'est de la reconnaissance
faciale avec du mois derrière. Bah, de
toute façon, les États sécuritaires se
mettent souvent en place euh au départ
euh leur faire épaver de bonnes
intentions, hein. Donc au prétexte de la
protection des populations, bah on rogne
petit à petit évidemment euh des
libertés et des bon je moi je suis je
vais vous dire pourtant Dieu sait que
j'ai une exigence sécuritaire forte mais
pas à n'importe quel prix. Voilà. et la
reconnaissance faciale, j'y suis pas
très à l'aise parce que au début, comme
on dit, ça va être utilisé pour
soi-disant de bonnes raisons et et
demain, quels sont les usages qu'on
pourrait en faire ? Des usages de
contrôle beaucoup plus larges qu'un
simple contrôle de sécurité et ça
là-dessus sur le principe, ça me met pas
très à l'aise.
Question internet. Peut-on m'expliquer
pourquoi on parle d'immigration qui
coûte cher alors que je paye une
cotisation avec 11.55 55 de COF pour les
caisses de retraite et 4.70 plus pour
les aides sociales.
Bah l'immigration coûte cher parce que
aujourd'hui il y a des études qui sont
faites. Je pense notamment une étude de
contribuable
associé mais il y a eu aussi des études
gouvernementales pour le coût qui oscile
entre une coût une charge nette de
l'immigration de 35 milliards par an à
54 milliards par an pour l'étude de
contribuable associé. Donc aujourd'hui
de fait l'immigration
contribuablecié c'est
c'est un sing tank économique
qui est tenu par qui ?
Qui est tenu par qui ? Par des
économistes. Mais bon mais je vous eux
ils font un 54000 ils ont fait c'est
Jean-Paul Gourvic, vous pouvez sur
vérifier si vous voulez qui avait fait
cette étude qui est un universitaire sur
ce sujet. Allez-y tracer tracer tout et
[grognement]
l'étude du gouvernement. Alors là pour
le coup, j'avoue humblement que je ne me
souviens plus mais elle elle se trouve
elle est à 35 milliards. C'est une étude
qui avait été commandée par le Premier
ministre directement. [grognement] Euh
là pour le coup, je mettrai un
commentaire si vous voulez après
moi-même pour remettre le truc. Mais en
tout cas, ce qui est sûr, c'est
qu'aujourd'hui, il y a une charge nette
de l'immigration qui est plus importante
que ce qu'elle que ce qu'elle rapporte.
Donc
vous êtes sûr de vous là ?
Oui.
Question internet. Pourquoi
l'immigration reste toujours leur sujet
de prédilection ? On voit son homologue
en Italie qui elle-même reconnaît que
l'immigration est absolument nécessaire
pour tenir leur leur marché du travail.
Ah bah pour moi, l'immigration est un
sujet central pour tout ce que je vous
ai dit depuis le début de cette
émission. Ça veut dire que c'est pas
l'immigration pour l'immigration, c'est
l'immigration pour les conséquences
qu'elle a sur le quotidien des Français,
la situation économique, la situation
sécuritaire, la situation culturelle.
Maintenant, je vais vous parler
franchement
par
mais je vous parle franchement depuis le
début. C'est vrai que c'est quand les
politiques vous disent "Je vais vous
parler franchement", c'est
on a envie de l' tar. Très inquiétant.
Oui, c'est terrible. Qu'est-ce que je
suis en train de devenir ? Non, vous
vous faites partie de l'élite.
Vous parlez franchement. Alors
cette question, [souffle coupé]
je finis. Moi, [grognement]
je ne souhaite pas que mon pays devienne
un pays musulman. Je peux pas vous le
dire plus clairement. Je ne souhaite pas
que
boudiste
l'islam non plus
l'islam devienne majoritaire en France.
Or, c'est ce qu'il va t'arriver si on
continue comme ça. Voilà, pour des
raisons numériques, démographiques. Et
je sais que partout où l'islam est
majoritaire dans les pays, sauf très
très rares exceptions comme le Liban et
encore ça tiendra peut-être pas très
très longtemps, la charia s'applique.
Voilà, la charia s'applique dans des
proportions plus ou moins. Et la charia
bah c'est un code civil et un code
culturel qui n'est pas compatible avec
le mode de vie à la française. Et donc
bah moi je je n'ai pas envie que mes
deux petites filles vivent dans cette
France là. Donc c'est pour cette raison
pour laquelle c'est un combat
prioritaire pour moi et on revient au
début de cet entretien parce que c'est
irréversible le jour où ça arrive.
Question internet. Où avez-vous fait
votre stage de 3e
?
Euh où est-ce que j'ai fait mon stage de
3e ? Euh je crois je crois que je l'ai
fait dans une animalerie.
Ben qui est de la mégisserie.
Euh non je sais plus où. Je je sais plus
où.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez du frexit ?
Euh alors sur le frexite, moi j'ai alors
déjà je tiens à dire parce que ça me
tient à cœur, j'ai pas un tabou de
principe, je dire je ne fais pas un
interdit moral d'une sortie de l'Union
européenne. Je pense juste que ça n'est
pas la solution aujourd'hui à nos
problèmes à court terme. Je pense qu'une
sortie serait plus douloureuse notamment
économiquement
que un maintien à l'heure actuel. Et je
crois qu'aujourd'hui avant de penser à
une sortie, commençons déjà par essayer
de changer les choses de l'intérieur, ce
qui n'a jamais été véritablement fait.
Et pour ça, il y a deux conditions. Un,
arrêter euh de s'enfermer dans le
soi-disant couple franco-allemand dans
lequel l'un des deux couche tout le
temps dehors. À savoir l'Allemagne et de
bah
savez pourquoi elle couche dehors ?
Ah ouais, parce qu'elle défend ses
intérêts au moins. Et et la deuxième
chose, on a une chance unique aux
prochaines élections du 9 juin puisque
justement euh les majorités sont en
train d'être composé, d'être changé. Et
[grognement] donc on voit pas,
ça fait peur. Ça fait peur ça.
Bah pas à moi. Ah non, moi au contraire,
je suis très contente quand je vois que
la Hongrie, l'Italie, la Suède, la
Finlande, tous ces pays sont ont basculé
ou sont en train de basculer. Bah au
contraire, ça nous permet demain de
pouvoir recomposer la majorité au
Parlement, donc changer la présence de
commission, donc changer la ligne de
l'Union européenne. Bah, commençons déjà
par essayer de faire ça avant de de
penser à une sortie. Et puis si dans 10
ans 15 ans, on se rend compte qu'on a
pas réussi à bouger une ligne et je ne
le crois pas, bah là on ver ce qui peut
être fait. Il me reste 3 minutes. Je
peux gratter 10 ?
Ouais 5 je vous accorde 5 minutes.
Oh vous êtes dur en affaire. Le logiciel
israélien Pegasus, ça vous parle ?
Oui.
On avait un ambassadeur français qui
était d'ailleurs chez eux.
Ouais, ça me parle. Je vais vous dire,
ça me parle même de façon personnelle
parce qu'il se trouve que le
téléphone de mon époux a [grognement]
été euh attrapé par le le fameux
logiciel Pegasus. Ouais. Donc euh
qui c'est qui l'a audité ?
C'est le service numérique informatique
du Parlement européen. Et là pour le
coup euh Apple a bien fait son travail
puisque les derniers iPhones sont un peu
plus sécurisés de ce point là. Donc il y
a eu une alerte qui a euh alerté donc
mon en effet sur le téléphone que il y
avait eu un logiciel
qui c'était et les services ont confirmé
ça. Donc oui oui, ça me ça me parle.
Alors après le système Pegasus, il a été
créé par les Israéliens mais il est
vendu euh à plein de pays donc on peut
pas savoir d'où viennent d'où viennent
ces ces types d'espionnage.
Et puis la Nessa, ils vous ont ils vous
enveront ils vous enverront pas
d'alerte.
A priori non.
Est-ce que vous êtes favorable ? Non.
Bon, on va passer euh je peux gratter 5,
c'est ça ? 5 donc
Oui, enfin c'était 5 il y a 2 minutes,
hein.
Non, non, non. Est-ce qu'il 45 [rires] à
partir de 45 ? Allez. Euh euh
vous aviez plein de questions, hein,
quand même. Bon, il va falloir revenir.
Voilà. Comment définit-elle les Français
de souche ? Bah des Français d'origine
française. Je sais pas, c'est marrant
parce qu'on se pose pas la question
quand on dit des Ivoiriens d'origine
ivoirienne, des Chinois d'origine
chinoise. Euh c'est c'est ça semble être
un sujet uniquement quand euh quand on
parle de la France.
Il y a il y a il y a des gens qui sont
très vulgaires dans le chat et on va
sévir.
Ah ouais, ils sont méchants.
Euh ils sont insultants et ça on
l'accepte pas. Donc Macron, c'est un mon
président, pas un mon président.
Ah non, c'est un c'est un mauvais
président et c'est
Non [rires] mais moi je je Non mais
c'est parce que en plus au-delà de de la
situation dans laquelle on est
aujourd'hui parce que il y a pas grand
chose qui se passe bien quand même he ou
qui va dans le bon sens
il a la galette des rois quand même.
Ce qui me voilà ce qui me terrifie le
plus chez cet homme-là c'est l'absence
totale de ce queet idéologique.
C'estàdire que il change d'avis surtout
à peu près tout le temps. Donc en fait
je on a l'impression qu'il fait joujou
il fait son stage de Lena en fait à la
tête du pays. C'est un peu inquiétant.
Est-ce que vous avez trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté ? Des
livres qui ont été importants pour vous
dans votre terraformation intellectuel,
dans les arcanes de votre pensée ?
[soupir]
Alors oui, j'ai j'ai
un livre que j'aime beaucoup qui est un
beau livre sur justement la France et sa
beauté qui s'appelle Les fleurs du lis
de Jacques Trémolet que j'aime beaucoup.
Un livre qui m'a marqué dans ma jeunesse
aussi, c'était un livre qui s'appelle
Historiquement correct de Jean Sévia qui
débunkerise un peu justement toutes
toutes les manipulations idéologiques
pardon autour des des certaines périodes
de l'histoire française justement sur la
place des femmes au Moyen-Âge, sur sur
l'esclavage, donc c'est c'est assez
intéressant et formateur politiquement.
Euh
après, j'ai lu des livres récemment qui
étaient des livres pas mal hein. J'ai
livre de Bruno Lemer.
Ah non, je pas lu c'est lequel [rires]
pour Ouais. Non, le livre de Bruno
Lemer. Je crois qu'il y en a certains
qui sont croustiillants pourtant. Euh
ou pas
ou pas mais je crois que ceux d'il y a
quelques années sont croustiants de ce
qu'on a compris. Non, j'ai j'ai lu un
livre dernièrement qui est pas mal sur
le wisme,
ce qui s'appelle La philosophie devenue
folle universitaire qui s'appelle
Bronstein. Et j'ai lu un livre qui m'a
intéressé. Je dis pas que j'ai un avis
définitif dessus parce que une fois de
plus, je suis pas une experte, mais
c'est le livre du
du conseiller climat d'Obama, enfin dans
l'ancien conseiller Climat d'OB qui
s'appelle climat la part d'incertitude.
Et donc lui, il est très intéressant
parce que il est il est scientifique de
formation et il prend justement toutes
les études y compris du J et voilà et il
les il les euh démocratis
et il explique une chose c'est que les
conclusions du JC qui sont à destination
des responsables politiques, la plupart
du temps ne correspondent pas exactement
à ce qui est dit dans les études. Et
donc il y a parfois beaucoup d'idéologie
dans ce qui est la partie je on dire
immergée
émergé plutôt de l'iceberg. Et lui, il
dit, il arrive à une conclusion, il dit
en gros, il y a un réchauffement
climatique indéiablement. Euh en
revanche, il dit il y a une part
humaine, c'est certain. Dire exactement
quelle est la proportion, on sait pas.
Et il dit "Ceux qui font des
trajectoires
vous mentent." En gros, aujourd'hui, on
n'est pas capable de savoir quelles sont
les trajectoires exactes. Donc je dis,
j'ai pas un avis définitif mais c'est un
drif que j'ai trouvé stimulant quand on
s'intéresse au sujet, bien qu'il soit un
peu un peu technique.
C'est quoi la maladie du pouvoir ? la
maladie du pouvoir
euh [soupir][souffle coupé] la maladie
du pouvoir euh l'arrogance peut-être
déjà. Donc du coup la perte de lucidité
sur soi-même, sur les autres et surtout
la perte de sens. On oublie pourquoi on
est là.
Est-ce que vous vous avez fini votre
réponse ?
Oui.
Est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations, une bouteille à la
mer ?
[soupir]
Euh un conseil pour les jeunes
générations, je dirais de de s'engager
de s'engager. Alors, c'est paraît bateau
mais en même temps, il y a plein de
formes d'engagement différentes.
C'est-à-dire que l'engagement politique
électoral, c'est une forme d'engagement.
Euh mais je considère aujourd'hui qu'il
y a plein Moi, je suis très attaché au
combat dit métapolitique, c'est-à-dire
le combat culturel en politique. C'est
aussi pour ça que j'ai monté une école
et je considère qu'aujourd'hui il y a
plein de combats à mener euh pour
sauvegarder, préserver, transmettre
justement la culture et l'identité
française dans plein de composantes qui
sont aujourd'hui menacées. Et donc bah
cette jeunesse là, on on l'attend là.
J'ai une phrase, je je finirai par là,
mais qui qui une phrase de la philosophe
Simon Veille qui disait "Le déracinement
détruit tout sauf le besoin de racine."
Je crois que cette jeunesse là, elle est
en partie déracinée mais elle a besoin
de racine et donc bah c'est à eux
d'aller rempoter la la plante.
C'est combien les frais d'inscription
euh
dans votre école ? Alors pour euh la
formation euh continue, on est autour de
1000 € et on fait des frais euh des
avantages, on va dire, si vous êtes euh
euh chômeur ou étudiant pour la
formation continue. Et pour euh le
master, on est à peu près autour de 5000
€ l'année.
On peut s'inscrire chez vous si on n'est
pas français.
Tout à fait. Et nous avons eu d'ailleurs
des étudiants étrangers nous arrivé.
Marion Maréchal, merci d'être venu. On a
invité Jordan Bardella et on a reçu une
fin de non recevoir
et et je voulais vous remercier de votre
courage parce que ça fait des années
qu'on essayé de vous avoir et vous êtes
venu très rapid. Je suis une femme, je
me fais désirer. [rires]
Ah, dans 10 ans.
Marion Marchal, merci.
Merci à vous.
[musique]